what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos we go
live three times a week every wednesday
thursday and saturday saturday and if
you turn on your notifications you'll
know when we're live second off um if
you guys want your comments to be read
to the panel super chat them and we will
read every single super chat guys the
super chats are going towards new
equipment for the channel i don't even
keep the super chats at this point we
just reinvest them into the channel so
send super chats that way you know we
can buy some cool new stuff
so um today we have some special guests
on the channel why doesn't everyone go
around say your name your age your
relationship status where are you from
and just like where they can find you on
social media
yeah all right cool it's your boy flashy
silla 24 years old
uh flashy still on instagram as well
i'm a content creator as well as an anr
so if any of you got
some high quality raptures you want to
give to me send that my way man the link
is in my bio let's go
hi
my name is aishlov
you can find me on instagram at i
schlove
i am from sorry
i am
25.
i don't know it's a joke i don't get it
i don't i don't get the joke
are you not 25
no she's 25. i'm 25 okay
okay
supposedly
okay so she's maybe 25.
yeah um
my relationship status is single with
two boyfriends
um
do they know about each other they do
now
[Laughter]
they got a guest
and yeah i'm happy to be here yeah thank
you for coming
hi i'm shimari i'm 21 from florida
living in london and you can find me on
my new youtube channel it's in the bio
word description
uh i'm terence from 36 i'm from brixton
i recently moved to cunnington my ig is
candy floss
chocolate muffin all the sweet stuff
and um yeah i'm in a relationship
uh i'm tea i'm from london south london
35 i'm married you can't really find me
on on socials
but yeah looking forward to this
okay
thank you guys for coming
um so today's topic is megan the
stallion and tory lanez
so um i'm gonna tell you guys like my
understanding of the story to begin with
so
i i just prep for this like today so if
there's anything i'm missing in the
comments let me know
but so apparently
megan was claiming that tory lanez shot
her in the foot in the past two years
she's been defaming him
allegedly right so she's been saying he
shot me in the foot
and like trashing him on social media
all this stuff i guess it impacted his
career as you know that would
and
she went live she said and i quote
um she was shot in both her feet and had
surgery
uh wait she was shot shot in both her
feet and had surgery to get the bolts
taken out i did not put my hands on no
one and he shot me but i tried to save
him
so
then tory lanez goes live after this and
claims that she was lying and not
telling the truth um and it was kind of
just like a he said she said but i think
in general like my my understanding is
the last two years people more believed
megan the stallion than they believed
tory lanez
um
until now there's a police report
that is coming out
basically saying that
there was no um so hold on hold on
i thought people believed
yeah i do think so really
is more i'm feeling the favor than megan
megan though no i'm saying before like
the first couple months it was megan no
i feel like that's what i'm she's being
bashed yeah i disagree because i think
if people like really believed megan
then tory lanez would have really been
cancelled i don't think he's nobody
i don't think his uh career has been
impacted like obviously like you would
think so but i don't think the
defamation has done anything to him no
no but i think because people know that
it's a bit fishy that's why no one's
reading well
so my understanding was at first people
took megan's side and maybe i don't know
when that changed but at first possible
i think she got sussed up
yeah i think what do you mean by that
like i think she like people started
reading more into the case
more more evidence started coming out
about it and then people put two and two
together wait what
people started realizing this is a bit
weird yeah so i'm gonna just go over
like what happened because not everyone
knows that's like watching so um
basically after tory lanez goes live so
what happened was they were i guess they
were all at a party um tory lanez um
megan the stallion's best friend named
kelsey we're all at kylie jenner's
birthday party and i guess like is tory
lanez like does he got it like that
because i guess he was sleeping with
both of them he never slept with her
that's what she's not apparently he was
he was g and megan's friend in it yeah
so um
i thought i heard dbg in both of them no
different not here
and this came out this came out because
kelsey um her friend went live and said
and i quote
um
like she says that she that she was
saying that megan was sleeping with guys
that she was talking to
so i kind of just insinuated that it
could be true could be not sure it's
just like a he said she said
um
but
basically um there was an argument
between all of them they're all
intoxicated and megan she went on
national television and said that tori
like
beat her yeah that beat her like hit him
shot her shot her what
no he was saying but i was saying yeah
with guilty yeah um
but it's interesting because her story
from on tv was different than her story
that she told
on live
so like for example on tv she said
um
that she never put her hands on anyone
but there's like multiple witnesses that
said that they were fighting and on top
of that like there was like nails that
were found and like other evidence of
like them fighting so if you're saying
like oh i didn't put my hands on anyone
that doesn't really make sense and it
doesn't line up with what the police
report said
and then um
on
top of that
it didn't also didn't make sense because
the security guard was with them
so like if you're tory lanez and you
have your security guard there he's not
gonna let you shoot somebody
allegedly right yeah
um but
now there's a police report and they're
saying that the doctor confirmed that
she was treated for glass and there
wasn't a gunshot yeah i heard she
stepped on glass yeah
and um
which is what i would not if i lied
about something i would not go on tv and
like yeah
you gotta consider that these guys have
very powerful lawyers in it megan and
tory so don't take in whoever's found
guilt you'll not kill you yeah and then
figure out for yourself yeah do you know
what i think they found they found a
yellow nail um a yellow pendant a nail
um
like on the ground where they were
allegedly like fighting
in my honest opinion what i think
happened in asia is i think that
megan and kelsey were both
in intimate relationships with tory
i think when they got intoxicated they
find out
i think megan and kelsey started
fighting
i think maybe kelsey brought up megan
and then i think that because it's over
tory tory gets to blame
he wasn't putting your willy everywhere
they've all got guns on them if he
wasn't putting your willy everywhere
this wouldn't have happened
says you know what i don't know he was
the guy's fault
no i'm not saying it's his fault i'm
saying i think that that's why megan is
trying to defame him and blame him
oh so you you think she's lying
i don't think she said the favor you did
you're trying to say like
she's trying to debunk what whatever you
saying in it
so you're saying he's lying i'm not
saying that he no i'm saying that
what she how she says it goes down i i
don't really think it went down that way
absolutely she said she stepped on glass
she said she got shot in her foot no but
she said the first that she stepped on
glass and then she said she only said
that to get out of trouble to get him to
get here
yes the doctor said that there was no um
yeah gun rings or anything but then i
saw somebody else's favorite said that
she's still got um
gunshot knowing that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because obviously a
bullet don't just go straight yeah
bullets
she's still got shards in the foot but
what i don't understand yet is you've
got glass in your foot that's still
there if you've got bullet stuff that's
still in your foot how are you still on
your knees twerking like that on your on
your arms that's what that's what they
were saying a couple days later she's
like she was on stage
but you just got no it's not so much my
darling
i'll be wrong it's also weird because
her friend texted the security at
7 27 am that
like saying
oh no megan got shot but it happened
like four hours earlier
oh wow yeah so if it really was an
emergency you would have been notified
there and then yeah so to me it's just
spooky yeah the whole thing's booking
it's just you know what it is you know
it is it's like
you know when you're driving down
clapham high road
2 am in the morning
on saturday
see that's what it is you just see
everybody fighting and nobody knows
what's happening because everybody's
intoxicated
i think i think this this whole thing is
just a problem between the two girls
yeah
he got involved because he was sleeping
with both yeah and then he's getting
blamed
i think i think i think he definitely
shot at her
but yeah wait wait
but from the from the from the start she
said from the start she said he shot me
i don't think he shot her
he probably shot at her like maybe shot
at the ground or whatever it is
the inconsistencies in her stories
that's what i'm saying i think the
gunshot definitely happened he i don't
think he intended to shoot her do you
feel what i'm saying like i can imagine
between two friends but then bro it's
like you don't shoot a gun and not
intend to not shoot someone you're going
to scare somebody
yeah or even just because you're drunk
yeah you know and that's in his mind
that's my boy so i can do whatever i
want kind of thing i know i ain't going
to shoot you or if you look at the um
what's her name blac chyna and rob
kardashian where she took out a gun
putting his face she went trying to
shoot him but do you know what i'm
trying to say kind of similar so i think
he definitely shot at her but from the
start she was saying he shot me but so
many inconsistencies yeah she said a lot
of different yeah yeah so like like she
has so many inconsistencies in her
stories like she said on national tv oh
i didn't put my hands on anyone when the
police report says you did there's
there's nails on the ground there's
neighbors that say they heard two girls
fighting
yeah so it's like why are you
drinking at that point
because if she's drunk yeah she might
think she's the nicest person in the
world i could never hurt anyone yeah
she's got you on camera all that being
wrong you're going to be doing something
with this case yeah the lawyers and
whatnot they really got considered the
context you know
because yeah yeah context is there i
just think that megan was definitely
fighting in the street like a ratchet at
home because i'm not being fun
i'm not being fun nothing here but
what what person here is going to let
somebody put their hands on them and sit
there and say i didn't put my hands on
nobody are you a monk
yeah foreign
she was definitely fighting everything
yeah yeah you've got to look like the
the the and this is why we're here
because you were trying to make it out
like he was something that it was
instead of telling the truth well and he
doesn't have any um like gun residue on
his hands
the only one that tested positive for it
was the friend i told you that the
friend
yeah
she shot at meg she shot you she had the
strap bro the three i don't think she
had the strap but bro i can reach for it
wow
[Laughter]
i think there was a gun between the
three of them i don't know who had it
but i think um megan's covering up for
her friend
who shot
but then why would
like because they're not friends anymore
yeah so why would she cover because
we're in this modern day where women
protect women you put the man under the
bus no because this is it because this
is it because you see in this modern day
why are you like bro like it's nothing
to do with me i weren't the one that was
[ __ ] you so you're gonna take the
problem with the one that was actually
[ __ ] you because that's the one that
has a low et button in this case they
both have a lot each other but that's
what i was saying just a minute ago i
reckoned the brethren done it and she's
saying it was tori because if tory
wasn't [ __ ] both of them then they
wouldn't be there fighting over him
that's not fair yeah but but i think
that's like that's the girl's fault you
pick who you sleep with like you go
you're gonna pick a world superstar like
yeah he's gonna
haven't you ever haven't you seen them
post though but it says something along
the lines of oh um that when get when
when guys are cheating on girls and then
the the girl wants to take it out on the
other girl but the girl wasn't the one
that was in the relationship do you
understand trying to say yeah yeah she
attacks the girl rather than her man do
you understand
she's blaming yeah yeah yeah no i mean
don't get me wrong like i would be salty
with my friend too you should be mad at
yourself i think if they were both
sleeping with each other i think it
could have been the case where they
didn't like they wouldn't they didn't
know because like i've i personally have
had it since like i've lost a friend
because we were like talking to the same
guy but i just was talking to him yeah
brother you knew there were you bro
that's true i feel like women always
know no but it's like okay
every time you don't have to tell
someone like that you're like talking
with someone like so even though that
they're friends
you don't tell every like i'm not gonna
tell everyone 100 everything about me so
but i think like
it seems like she knew because of the
way that she responded to her on the
live
because the friend was on live saying
that you go for the guys that i'm like
dating behind my back basically
so megan was the jealous one it seemed
like megan was going because i think the
friend and tori were talking first yeah
and then megan yeah but wasn't their
thing on social media before the
shooting like that megan was dating tory
picked her up or something like that
there was at some awards yeah yeah they
were dating they were definitely close
speculation that means i think everyone
was aware that tori was sleeping both of
them yeah no because
i don't i don't think so because you can
be friends like just because uh you and
i are friends like and i'm a a woman and
you're a guy doesn't mean that we have
to be sleeping no no no no i'm certain
no 100 but like obviously the the aura
before the shooting and the vibes was
that tory megan tory megan like it was a
it was almost a power couple thing
without it being officials you know i
mean so it's like i'm sure everyone knew
that they were all [ __ ] man
i'll be honest i feel like that's
american man
yeah you got this for a couple of ones
you [ __ ] anyone yeah i'm sorry no
offenses
it just sounds like it sounds like a
[ __ ] show but i remember when it came
out on the news and it was it was
one-sided it was megan was in the right
yeah
that's why
it coincided with like [ __ ] that was
happening in the world at the time
whereby
because i feel like now everyone can see
the toys yeah yeah and then there's like
oh [ __ ] we don't know the truth the only
thing that's been consistent is tori
lane's protesting his innocence
that's the only thing that's not
consistent he's very loud about it
that's what i'm saying no he can't be
anymore he really
can't speak on it anymore there's a
protective order so tory lanez cannot
defend himself but he or he can defend
himself but he cannot mention anything
given to him by his counsel so basically
everything in the case so he he there
was a tweet that got him arrested
so so it's like meg the stallion can go
live and say all this [ __ ] but he can't
say [ __ ]
she's already said that that's her
accusations but in terms of what he's
learned during the case or whatever yeah
that has to stay confined in it so yeah
yeah it's kind of deep but well to be
honest she's the victim she's treated
that's the victim in here until yeah
yeah yeah the victim yeah so
yeah she gets a priority
until proven guilty okay so does anyone
think so you think that she she was shot
i don't think she was shot i think i
think she was shot she was shot at do
you think she was shot at exactly
i'm gonna say yeah yeah okay what are
you doing
yeah i think even though he has no gun
residue on his hands you don't think
that i didn't know that detail yeah i
didn't know that detail to be fair but
then he could he could have had a glove
on it no it's pretty no no
no it's pretty it's pretty hard to get
like you can't really get gun residue
off your hands yeah like that's pretty
difficult yeah yeah yeah yeah there's no
cctv in this place
you know how i'm picturing it i'm
picturing it as like a tour bus
situation or like a van or they're just
leaving the stage or something like that
you know what i mean i don't know bro
yeah does anyone else anyone else i
reckon it was kelsey you think i reckon
chelsea drawed for the ting
i said you know what you're a big [ __ ]
i can't fight you hold
this
i think it was a friend that's all well
that would be deep that would be deep if
it was the friend for megan to know it
was the friend and i'll go on live tv
and national television and be like it's
tori i feel like if that tory would have
rather put i'm sorry i think megan would
rather put tori under the bus than her
friend even though they're not friends
no more knowing it's not the guy knowing
he never it's nothing but because we're
living in the world where just put the
guy under the bus yeah it doesn't matter
what it is i protect you girl yeah yeah
to protect her i think it's despite him
no i think it's despite him
i think here that
kelsey
is a nobody i think a violation is a
violation and because she feels violated
bro kelsey you're irrelevant we don't
even care you're gonna go back to the
roaches we don't care about you but you
see tory you you think you could what
you're lucky it's not me because i'd put
you on granddaughter
no they don't know who it was it wasn't
registered it was just it was just a
strategy
now why would you make them i've written
it with stories because
the handgun was in the sidelock position
it was in the front passenger seat um so
and the megan the stallion said she was
in the back seat but the police report
said that she was in the front
bro can megan tell the truth megan was
drunk she don't know what happened that
night yeah
she's coming back to her in phases i
think one thing also um is like when you
go into an interrogating room like it's
like pressure
not necessarily
but if you're telling the truth what's
the pressure do you mean no no i don't
think pressure but like say if it's
something like traumatic in this
instance like this would be a traumatic
event um trauma can cause you to like
lose like or like tell a different story
and say like if you're like first off
saying something and then you have a
second to digest like the information
your story can change
right
but they both got lawyers right away so
they didn't like they weren't
interrogated right away did you get in
trouble for like changing your story or
off your line yeah once you commit to a
story
it's more so like when you're in the
court because it's like um
like i'm telling the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth but like
in the police room like technically yeah
yeah you are but
obviously things like when you're when
you go through a case
things can change along the way or like
not that the evidence changed but
information [ __ ]
like yeah like so like it will change
along that side um
yeah yeah so um
my belief is that i think that this and
the amber heard in johnny depp trial um
i think we're gonna see more and more
like
cases coming forward where women weren't
lying
as a result of feminism and the metoo
movement
because there was a movement that said
believe all women believe all women and
i think crazy women took advantage of
that
i'm not going to lie yeah i'm going to
say something and i want people like to
discuss in the comments or you guys here
i'm asking you a lot don't you not think
the law works in the women's favor like
in in modern day well well it's set up
in the women's favor i would say it
works in the world so let's say for
example yeah like
um someone calls dead in the middle of
the night two people screaming and
shouting at each other a police officer
comes to the door and they they can see
that people are like distraught yeah i
mean a man and a woman they're gonna
decide on the woman's side like
like naturally no i i'm not i'm not mad
at that though i'm not mad at that you
know what i've seen from myself
yeah because you know what yeah i've
actually had like a real life experience
yeah
with the domestic
and um when the police came like the
woman police officer she instantly went
and sided with my ex whereas it was the
man who sympathized with me so i
wouldn't say like it works for the women
in favors like i feel like if like
if they come to a scene and people are
distraught or whatever that naturally
they might go to calm the woman down
first because obviously from the
beginning of time women have been
labeled as hysterical creatures do you
understand but i don't think that they
favor women women are a men get four
times the sentencing for the same crime
the thing is i feel like the law
protects and favors i think it protects
women i think it protects the victim but
i think in the majority of cases people
say that the victim
are women
but what you were saying earlier like
i've seen it outside a club where a girl
was literally slapping her boyfriend
slapping him up because he was ignoring
her and when he held her it's like stop
the police were like yo what are you
doing
it's like you didn't say that when she
was beating him up that's like because
exactly what i'm trying to give like
yeah that you know i mean so when stuff
like that happens like if police pull up
now
and they see a male and a female
fighting
they of you have to favor the woman
because obviously like even anatomy wise
like but if you saw a man and a woman
fighting yeah and you tried to intervene
you're gonna be like yo i need to stop
you yeah yeah yeah and i'll need to calm
down my man instead of her you know what
i mean i'll just tell my man sure
instead of her you're all children
because you you i've heard a lot of
stories um of men that are abused and
like they they don't but they don't
really i've got bridges that being
abused right but they can't do nothing
because it's a woman yes and right from
the soul you can't you abuse a woman
back you know i mean but i think i think
if you if you had this is how i was
raised i think so you don't hit anyone
unless you want to be hit yeah i don't
and i i do think a lot of uh that's a
dangerous thing no no i know i don't
think so because a lot of women abuse
the fact that they're a woman like oh
i'm gonna be the [ __ ] out of you but oh
i'm a woman you can't hit me no if you
hit someone i don't care what your sex
is what you identify as if you hit
someone they have the right to hit you
back so don't hit anyone unless you want
to be hit but then you're going to have
a guy who's his wife or his girl is
beating him and he can [ __ ] her up if he
wants to yeah but no but he's true not
to but he doesn't acknowledge that oh
he's a victim of domestic violence he's
like if i say that i'm a [ __ ]
like also like where it's like oh well
the guy like hitting the woman back the
thing is it's like as as a male you're
biologically stronger than a a female so
and and defending yourself you don't
have to like beat the [ __ ] out of them
but you like you can how how you're
saying like oh like grab the woman like
yeah you can you can
like
you can do something to gain your side
back without like like having her like
overpowering
people
but yeah if you if you if you want to
hit like a dude then get then be
prepared to get slapped like a dude like
i
think
if you went up if you went up to the
rock okay yeah and you hit him yeah and
then you get decked back yeah nobody's
going to feel like i have to hold you
yeah why i have to hold it
but people will say to you you shouldn't
have hit the rocket
back yeah you're an antagonist right and
so i'm saying like like if a girl if
it's the the arguments like the girl's
weaker but there are guys that are are
skinnier than other guys or like smaller
than other guys like the rock is gonna
beat up any dude in this room and if any
of you hit him you're stupid for doing
that yeah just like a woman like i'm
sorry you're gonna hit like a dude you
should get yeah you prepared to get him
in that situation i said guy you're kind
of talk from a very young age depending
on your upbringing that even if that
happens you have to almost be the bigger
person yeah yeah and not strike back
yeah but that's not what you're talking
about you can defend yourself without
like going him yeah
i would say yeah that
the way how
like i've been brought up and not how i
bring up my son is if a girl hits you
you go and get your sister and make your
sister demolish her
okay
the other day they was playing outside
and my son coming crying said that
someone slapped him in the face i said
you know what you've got do you beat her
ass
and ever since the dawn of time like i
can't lie ever since i've known like
when a girl wants to put her hands on me
or even just chat [ __ ] to me bro i'll go
call one of my ratchet hoes bro from
yeah me one of the girls that man knows
and just told him yo i can't i got a
problem with this girl yeah pissing me
off bro yeah sort that out please see my
brother's never had that problem because
i'm mentally unstable
oh man but um yeah i kind of feel like
it should be dealt with in a moment
though no you know we've seen it being
dealt with in a moment with the whole
like chris brown rihanna thing
that got dealt with in a moment and look
what happened to chris brown he's
thinking yeah but he's [ __ ] over body
decked yeah yeah yeah yeah he [ __ ] her
up apparently he she was [ __ ] yeah
that's what i mean
i've been in that situation in the whip
as well like yeah and
i couldn't hear so i started hitting the
card you know i mean
i understand that's that's why in the
last show when you were saying the guy
should hit back
i i understand that but if he does and
he gives into the rage one punch is
going to turn into this
that's the problem is that like if you
guys do then you guys get in trouble but
i'll fight for your
dangerous rights i'll march the streets
yeah
because you just keep going and going
and going yeah there's no gauge yeah
because you've been holding it up the
whole time and when you explode you
explode
but why do you think it is in society we
have this initial inclination to believe
women like regardless of their
credibility
i don't think women are believed i don't
think they are because that's like black
victims or rape and stuff that's what
i'm saying i don't know
say grape say grape sorry like i
wouldn't say that they are almost like
always believed because that's about
like not a lot of grape trials yeah make
it to court and then when it comes to
great i feel like that's that's
different because
equally the women could be lying and
there's no way to verify who's lying or
who's telling the truth whereas with the
domestic violence you can tell that
there's no with domestic violence the
woman's black and blue yeah there's
with grape it's like well with grape you
need evidence
and yeah and a lot of
a lot of the cases are thrown away right
or ignored it's not necessarily women
aren't believed it's that like in order
to convict someone you need evidence
that they did it and if you don't
provide that but even in this like
scenario we're assuming that the girls
that can't prove it are telling the
truth yeah like they could be lying we
don't know but if you don't have
evidence to back it up like
yeah i feel like women have believed 100
like if it was me if my sister called me
and said it's tricky and said such and
such with my with my ex or with my man
or whatever i'm going to believe her
immediately it's just that's your sister
though even if it's about even if it was
a stranger on the road i'm just going to
believe i'm not going to take action but
my instincts are just your inner thought
is to believe you know what i mean like
i thought that means i think it depends
on what you know though right so if you
knew that your sister lied a lot and she
called you yo you'll be like no that's
what i'm saying if even if it was a
stranger if you're on our way back now
if you see a woman running asking for
help yeah saying the guy's done this
we're not gonna be like yeah but did he
we're in this
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but women take advantage of
that like i think there's certain women
that know that
you asked any girl about her ex oh he
was so toxic he was the word like it's
never what they did wrong the guy is
always the bad guy no i take
accountability i say like i used to have
this problem with my ex like
my women would get into it
like the way he would tell the story oh
she's crazy she done x y and z to me but
then when i told a story okay this is
what happened we was chilling and then
he done x y and z so then i got my car
and ran him over
[Laughter]
wait wait you got your car and you ran
him over yeah that but what the reason
why wait was because
the reason why
it was because he done something to me
first so because he done something
what did he do vivid imagination okay
what did he do what did he do
what did he do yeah to get ran over like
a car doesn't matter it doesn't matter
the fact is he started it yeah yeah
i'm gonna tell you what he does
he put his hands on me in it and i knew
i wasn't in a position to fight him
but because he put his hands on me and
it hurt me i needed to hurt him back so
i decided to hurt him in the car
fair enough was he good
was he good like did he live yeah it
wasn't at high speed definitely lived he
literally just flew up into the air and
came down again
was it four by four
no it was a polo it was his polo
actually
i have a question
does everyone believe her
i do you know i kind of do i really do
this is why men don't want to hit women
back because they can get run over by
their own politics yeah no but this is
what i'm saying it's like the
at the most i've had like dishes being
dashed at me and that so i believe it
yeah jesus christ you're saying the
wrong thing yeah yeah you know good yeah
so i could never
oh but then there's also been times when
i've put my hand on on a guy i'm [ __ ]
up
and then i'm gonna where did you did you
antagonize the guy i put my hands on him
first okay well then my hands on him
first but then but then i would sit
there and i'd be like alright cool but
you didn't have to do me like that
you didn't have to do that slap me in my
face
someone did not expect them to defend
themselves
no no i hear what you're saying yeah
yeah but you have to hear what i'm
saying yeah a guy here is naturally
stronger than you yeah i know so if i'm
hitting you if i'm hitting you yeah i'm
hitting you no no but the fact that you
know that yeah
i'm not justifying it what i'm trying to
say to you is [ __ ] is that you see he
said that how one punch can turn into 20
punches when you're a female you don't
have to punch it you don't have to punch
a female 20 times so even if you wanted
to punch me once that would have been
more than enough
but no i do understand that and i i do
believe that men have like biologically
men are stronger but the case in point
is
one you shouldn't hit anyone if you
don't want to be hit rather rather they
like don't have to go all the way when
they're like retaliating that's that's
up to them but you're not like you can't
hit someone and say oh well
i'm i'm weaker than you so don't hit me
back no
i get where she's coming from i've got a
couple good punches in any way so no i
don't do that but i'm
right or wrong like you can't justify
saying like oh i'm i'm the weaker person
and not like no i think if you hit like
a dude expect to get hit by a dude like
yeah but if you're here
i'm just saying if i hit you three times
it doesn't mean you should hit me that's
what i was going to say like sometimes
when i play fight with my brother uh-huh
i might poke him
and you punch me like 20 times i'm like
bro you too but you know what it's like
a man can't see you oh you know what to
equal your one punch i gotta do a
[Laughter]
is
so it's like if you if you started it
that's not
like you shouldn't hit him definitely
and if my man gave you a bang back
you'll think [ __ ] oh
no no if that bang was solid it should
be not because you'll be out for a while
you have to take this
out none of these [ __ ] have got solid
bangs
[Laughter]
i feel like you are more likely to
believe
a female in that situation not saying
that women don't like women [ __ ] lie
but i think
generally speaking more men
abuse women physically than women lie
about being abused 100 percent i think
because of that you naturally give that
sort of nickname you don't believe so no
no because you have to we have to
remember yeah not a lot of men were like
built like us for example
i mean so saying that
i'm sorry
i'm different
it's like obviously
when a lot of men know they have the
physical power over women and a lot of
men are just [ __ ] all so they can't
bully man they're not bullying girls
yeah okay
it's just that they take their anger out
on on their wives well i think i think i
think that like you take away the
consequences in a society more people do
it and we've eliminated consequences for
women so that's why i think more women
do it because like some dudes probably
have the capacity to hit a girl and
probably like would but they choose not
to because they don't want to go to jail
yeah yeah but like women can do that and
yeah like well like what's to happen if
a girl hits you and you call the police
like oh is it i've been arrested
what were you going to talk about um so
i'm going to touch on what you said
about like boys bling girls whatever
now i've actually got a real life
experience
she started secondary school in last
year
and um this boy in year nine has like i
would say been bullying her
and um
when the teacher called me about it like
i went absolutely ballistic at him
because what he said to me was that
oh i told her not to worry about it
because he probably likes her and i said
and this is what is wrong with [ __ ]
society because how how are you
normalizing domestic abuse at 11 years
old you did you telling my daughter that
he oh don't worry about it he probably
likes you what are you trying to teach
my daughter that any man that likes her
is going to treat her like [ __ ] can i
touch you
i'll be honest here i was in primary
school and like this is the first time
i've ever seen this on content it's like
i had anger management when i was in
primary school in it and all the punch
up girls no no no i didn't i didn't i
didn't but obviously girls used to tease
me a lot in it because they know i'll
just snap like that yeah yeah i'll still
use just
tease him quickly
throwing chairs yeah i mean so obviously
there's this one girl that'll do it
constantly every every day every day and
it's like one of the teachers will cut
take me out class they'll be like all
right she it's because she fancies you
that's why she's doing that so just
ignore her
brother i used to think cool i'll ignore
her she's still in my head [ __ ] that man
yeah i mean so obviously that carried on
into secondary school so i hear what
you're saying that that's it normalizes
it and i think yeah that teachers need
to stop doing that well they normalize
abuse against men though like i think
more so than women like for example
there was um a view clip where they were
joking about chopping a dude's like off
because he cheated and she'd like
chopped his now imagine if imagine if
like that happened if a man did that to
a woman he chapter like tits off because
she cheated
i think it's wrong on both sides
girls get murdered because they've been
cheating yeah yeah when i was in jamaica
when i was in jamaica they was they had
candles all down the road and i said to
my uncle why is there so many candles he
goes oh somebody died the move pulled
over now i said oh he died they said ah
the woman
um a man catcher united fox
there are certain cultures that will do
that even if it's not cheating even if
it's
you know
whatever it is conception than the rule
i don't think most men are out here
murdering cheaters
no but even even not like
say even in a relationship like even
when i'm on the road and stuff um
doesn't matter where i'm at if a guy's
like trying to move to me i would just
give them my information like like my
number or whatever because i value my
life and i don't know how they're going
to snap this outfit
yeah because i don't know i don't know
who you are and not saying that i can't
fend for myself but i don't know how how
far i can defend myself for one and two
i value my life over saying like oh no i
i would not like to talk to you because
after i walk away i can block you
you don't know where i live you don't
know all these things so i i'd rather
just say here's my info yeah okay yeah
i'll talk to you later
i'm not mad when you literally don't
know who you're talking to like
literally a guy can just step to a girl
right but that's not the rule though i
don't think most men are like killing
girls i don't know
um i don't think most men are killing
girls because they've been rejected
they're not killing but that like i do i
do think so like a lot of violence
happens like when you get there they're
they are so insecure
yeah some guys do take
they're wrong
right right but it's the exception it's
not the rules yeah it's not killing in
physical violence yeah right then i
think some guys just can't take them no
i'll be real i don't understand
lower level yet okay
what percent of men do you think do that
what killing and what not just
any violence so what percent of men do
you think are violent against women
oh
i think probably like 50. i think 50
percent yeah but you're saying that
you're saying no
as a male no okay no no no i'm saying
this as a female don't it doesn't why
why do we bring up gender what like a
man has an opinion on anything it
doesn't matter if he's a man or a woman
because he's not going to be the one
experiencing who cares if he's been
through an experience is what you're
saying true or untrue like who gives a
[ __ ] if it's a dude
it's what you're saying accurate are you
saying that fifty percent of your
experiences have been violent
with a male so out of out of this group
you think half of them
yeah i've pushed up a couple women in my
time still
[Laughter]
like i would say maybe that in my
experiences with men
i think of all of the experiences that
i've had with men i think
three of them have been violent towards
me
i think
maybe
five of them have threatened violence
towards me but i've never actually been
violent
and then the rest they're just
they just take the bad up i think people
forget they're intimidating so what
percentage
so i would say maybe
a quarter
a quarter it is not that high but you're
bad enough exactly but it's it's also
like the menu yeah
true yeah i know i've dealt with ghosts
like you like you don't know well i'm
like yeah
[Laughter]
well you attract what you are you you
talk about getting yourself no me saying
that i'm not saying about guys that i've
been with like
because i would i would not be with
someone like that's like abusive and
obviously like
no one is willing you don't know that
though no but no
no i'm saying i'm saying myself the
moment that i'm seeing that i'm gone
[Music]
for one horror story
i i do know that but i'm telling you for
me
i'm gone yeah like if you have one
horror story yeah there's gonna be a
hundred or a thousand stories on horror
stories but you're gonna remember that
one horror story more yeah and it's
gonna be like [ __ ] half the guys are
pricks
but is that what's really happening
right yeah i saw a guy move to a girl
and she just didn't want to talk to him
he's like why aren't you talking to me
like i got a boyfriend oh who's your
boyfriend i'm going to do this i'm going
to do that like why bro i don't even say
even at the lowest level just dms bro
i've seen man move crazy just getting
internet is different you know people
get people get a lot more bolder on the
internet no but i think he's saying in
person yeah no yeah in person but even
to the lower level level which is social
media when guys don't get responses from
girls like they're replying yo what are
your ugly
what the [ __ ] bro like how do you not
even have the pride to do that i have a
stat so um
of domestic abuse crimes recorded by the
police 26 percent were committed against
men
um and it says
half of male victims 49 failed to tell
anyone that they were a victim of
domestic abuse and are two and a half
times less likely to tell anyone than
female victims agreed
because i don't want to be
seen as a [ __ ]
yeah
i'll be interested to know how recent
this that was because i think 10 years
ago and i'm not asking for you to look
it up but 10 years ago that wouldn't be
as high as that is
because i think men are encouraged more
now to speak up about stuff yeah
no men still won't though no i think
then i put it i think now we just take
away the consequence like if you take
away like when you look at things from a
policy perspective you have to think
about like what is this policy
encouraging and when you see like the
inequalities in the justice system like
men
i i just i don't think women are
punished at the same way like men are
they are you think they deserve to be
yeah yeah i do i do i think everything
should be equal yeah
okay i think so if you if you hit a guy
let's get the bill
no i'm saying in this
i wouldn't mind doing that and i say
that because i don't do anything that i
couldn't like do on my own so i if any
any activity that like i'm not doing if
i can't 100 if you went on a date with a
guy and he said to you let's split the
bill how would you feel i wouldn't mind
because i'm young so save like if i'm
going with a younger person but even if
i'm not going with like someone that is
like
closer to my age
if they're i'm not their responsibility
yeah so like obviously it is nicer like
if they're gonna pay
it doesn't matter if it's a guy like
even if it's not like a uh even like a
platonic thing
if i'm going out with someone and they
want to pay sure that's fine because
that's less money that i'm spending but
i'm never gonna be expecting someone
you're always gonna have money in your
pocket to pay for your hell yeah yeah
hell yeah why am i expecting you to do
something
well if somebody asked me to split the
bill
i would literally cover the whole no
i'll be honest i'll never speak in that
case
make a statement
what did you say i said if a guy ever
asked me to split the bill i would just
pay for the whole bill and that person
would never see me again
did you get offended by that wouldn't
you
100 yeah
because you see me i mind my business i
go about my life and i'm on my business
if you
are talking to me it's because you've
seen something that you like
you didn't have to guys one at a time
one at a time
in my yard eating my rice in the fridge
what happens if you see a guy you like
then what are you saying
me i'm a bougie baby
that's what i'm saying what are you
doing before
um
like like on the team not let's go on a
date like yo let's link
no up never done that
okay yeah fair enough okay guys i'm
gonna read super chats for a second um
okay so guys thank you so much oh wait
let me refresh the page thank you so
much for the super chat so far as you
guys know we're trying to get some
upgrades in the studio so all the super
chats right now are being donated
towards i think what what's our next
thing-ish new camera
we got the soundboard so yeah new new
camera new camera okay then you can get
like a close-up of the guests faces so
if you want to see that
sun send super chat so okay
let me oh my god guys i pushed the wrong
button hold on
um
i got it hold on hold on
okay
so
it started from
sentience with a 50 super chat thank you
so much
[Music]
if um if you stop putting your willy
everywhere this wouldn't have happened
and this turn then turns around and says
she's not blaming him it's this kind of
bipolar rubbish who um rubbish who
claims to be a single with two
boyfriends focus on yourself gents don't
dip into crazy five dollars from from
nope nope nope
five no five dollars from megan is doing
roc nations dirty work that's all it is
a goose is being fattened up for flotter
slaughter 4.99
um even fifty dollars from zen teams
even if trauma can cause you to lie what
stop megan from coming back to the set
to set the record straight oh right
accountability is a woman's kryptonite
in domestic violence violence cases
without any evidence approximately
ninety percent of the time the man is
arrested without question two dollars
from mickey the uk guys are gross are
grossly blue pill this is pathetic
um let's see let's
i think is there one more at the end or
now um but please i just want to say
here that is you shouldn't call people
bipolar and stuff because mental health
is real and that's so disrespectful yeah
i agree but i think he meant the comment
not your personality no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no like you know
you said
mike tyson used to slap his wife but he
would knock out all the guys in that
room the issue is some men have a
violence problem regardless of gender
gender men get the worst of men's
violence they're murdered more i agree
um 20 um from just human if you engage
with violence you sign up for whatever
comes next if you slap a person and they
go that pull up with a strap that's the
game anytime you choose to fight your
life is on the line okay
um we have one more super chat from
adeleke
[Music]
um
megan is just doing rock nation's dirty
work that is all it is a goose is being
fattened up for slaughter oh you read
that one yeah
that's tough but i i hear that though i
hear what you're saying about the
bipolar though because it is a big it is
a big thing like mental health do you
understand you shouldn't really shame
people like that
it's bad
um because i do have bipolar and so what
i'm proud
i hear you man um
well i think i think the point is like
like that mental health is real and
that's like like obviously but it
doesn't excuse like treating people a
certain way
like hitting someone like that that's
not fair to the person
no the comment was talking about okay
something she said
um about megan but then the other thing
was contradictory to the initial thing
so then the comment was like is this
kind of bipolar mentality yeah
yeah we
um
okay so um
let me
see what's next on the
um
um okay so what did you guys think of
so are we in agreement then about the
metoo movement that it was like a bad
thing in the end
i can't say i can't say it was a bad
thing
i would say
i would say that and bad things came
from it but i can't look at the me too
movement as a whole and say it was a bad
thing okay um yeah
a madness was being done if i'm if i'm
being honest here like people were being
exploited and in that situation it
happened to be that women were being
exploited and the perpetrators needed to
be found out and called out yeah but i
think a lot of people jumped onto the
bandwagon yeah and a lot of lives and
careers were destroyed unfairly i feel
as a result of that so it served the
purpose but then it also did a lot of
damage and a lot of hurt um
it's just like what you were saying
about um morgan freeman yeah yeah so if
you if you apply the me to movement
concept morgan freeman should should be
held accountable for i think he's like
slapped a girl's ass or woman's ass in
the 70s or something like that but it's
like for him it's like that's what
people did in the 70s you just left
everyone's asses kind of thing
um
but yeah now you're going to go after a
guy who has a career like that
so i it kind of got out of hand but then
how do you regulate that like you know
well i just think you need evidence like
we live in this society where it's like
believe people with no with no evidence
yeah and people can like like a girl can
accuse a guy of something with like
nothing and ruin a career or like get
public thousands of people online like
watching him
like tarnishing his reputation with with
no evidence that it happened yeah i
think even when evidence exists to the
contrary sometimes the justice system
fails men especially in the last five
years whereby
judges or whoever aren't even looking at
the evidence that proves that the guy is
innocent but still because you're a guy
and there's a big movement it's easier
to sort of go against you and fall on
the sword rather than
stand up and then it's like oh women are
more vulnerable now and then they're
more victims and it's like
there needs to be fairness whoever's a
perpetrator needs to be done for right
right because it was a belief believe
all women like
i can't belie i used to be everywhere
and i remember like being
back then thinking this is madness
because i know some crazy [ __ ] yeah i
know some crazy [ __ ] you should not
believe i think that's so dangerous
though
it's so dangerous but the movement was
so big that if you spoke against it
everyone's on you everyone would come
after you and you get cancelled right
but now this whole johnny depp thing
it's almost like a breath of fresh air
kind of thing
because it sort of brings back some sort
of balance to say well actually
maybe some women do lie and it's not
just whatever a woman says it's true i'm
not saying amber heard
is a liar and that johnny depp isn't
whatever it is but it at least brings
another conversation
some sort of balance yeah there's at
least that conversation to be like what
if whereas before it wasn't what if it
was we don't care you're a guy she said
you did this you didn't get [ __ ] up
and they um
they
they would give like i think that the
news outlets should be held accountable
that were pushing amber heard [ __ ]
to be honest you're giving a girl a
platform with no evidence that's so
irresponsible yeah but news i think
don't think they actually have an
obligation
they just have to say what's what's been
reported yeah and what's being reported
a lot of the times the whole vibe of
things comes from social media and
social media are pushing this feminist
movement yeah when which is like a
believable woman thing which they're
still pushing no but i'm saying like
like they gave her an op-ed
so it's one thing to say these are the
facts and this is what she said and
there's another thing to like let her
write an article on your paper
but all they care about is are people
going to read that paper yeah i know
because you've got no obligation to
find anything what's an op-ed
i don't it's like when you get
i don't know because they can edit they
can be an editor of
an article i guess but yeah um
a newspaper paid
page opposite the editorial page devoted
to personal comment feature articles
yeah so if it's personal comments i just
know she like wrote it
and she didn't say him by name but like
it almost seems like there should be
laws in place that that punish women and
men honestly for for going on public
platforms and talking saying [ __ ] that's
not true and it just seems for like a
little point
in
in our history like there really was no
punishment during that movement
do you guys agree disagree no i agree i
don't even know what that movement was
me too
oh me too yeah
yeah the me too movement and the
believer women yeah yeah no that's that
was a bit mad because you could see that
some of them are liars
some of them are clout chasers
but then i i saw i
when that was the whole metoo movement
was going on i used to see the sort of
graph here that would say
like two percent of women would lie
about being graped
and then it would be like 98 are telling
the truth so what does this really mean
yeah it made me think what do i believe
who does that survey though like how
does happen how do they yeah
how do you know that they're telling the
truth well the one in five stats they
always say like one in five women have
been sexually assaulted that's not true
how is that not true
no because they include things like like
a guy grabbing your ass at a ball
i was sexually assaulted in in when i
was in year eight what would you say
sexual assault when i was in year eight
yeah before i went to school um i went
to mcdonald's to get mcflurry before i
went to school and as i was queuing up
here this man he came behind me
and i bearing a man i'm in yeah i'm in
my school uniform and he was like
groping my bum and at first i thought it
was in my head so i kind of like moved
away from him but lo and behold there he
was again behind me groping my bum and
then i knew no it's not in my head i am
being sexually assaulted right now did
you know it at the time yeah i went to
school when i told teachers but i'm
saying like okay that's gross he should
not have done that like that's
disgusting he's touching an underage
girl like that that's messed up so
that's gross but like my point was that
there's a difference like they made it
seem like at the time one in four women
was getting graped when like like i've
had how do we i've had i've i've i've
had my butt grabbed at a bar i wasn't
traumatized i was like get the [ __ ]
yeah but that's not that but that's
still such a
question
can i just ask questions because i just
feel like here that there are different
definitions of what grape could be 100
because you see sometimes yeah you could
find yourself with a guy and he could be
pressuring you so much you don't want to
do it but you could be scared you could
be uncomfortable and you might just end
up giving away giving yeah so is that
great there's like there's there's
there's like because he pressured you
coercion yes that is depression yeah i
don't think so yeah no it is whether you
think it or not that is classified as
great wait what would you define as
coercion let me just understand like
manipulation i would say manipulation if
if i as a guy i'm fully aware the woman
is not interested in having sex whether
it's today or whether we had sex
yesterday and today she's not interested
if i'm fully aware and i
i pressure her whether let me let me
just so okay me and you we go on a date
right after the day we go back to my
place
and i i say i don't want to hook up with
you and then you try to convince me
is that coercion i would say it is yeah
yes okay i think sometimes i don't i i i
just
say something
because if he's in your place here you
could feel intimidated so you could end
up no no why did you go there yeah why
did i bring him because so say for
example we went on a date now and then
we agree you agreed to come back to mine
i asked you do you want to come back
tomorrow we have drinks and whatnot we
you come back to mine and then we're in
the same bed
and then i try to emotion you now and
then you're like no no no i tried i
tried to like draw me i tried to get
these cracking i tried to motion you
i tried to motion i tried to get things
cracking yeah and then obviously you're
like no no no
and then i'm trying to like yo i'm
trying to sweet you up
and you're still like no i'm like all
right cool that's it
don't say that's it yeah they will keep
on going and going and going okay
turns into a yes
but then some some girls will be like oh
you're not up front because you didn't
really push it
because
so i've been in situations where guys
pressured me and i told them to get the
f out yeah like it's not like pressure
and
like trying to get it cracking do you
know what i mean yeah no there is but
that's what i'm saying if ultimately you
know she's not on it yeah no matter what
yeah and she ends up doing it because of
like how is the guy supposed to know but
how is the guy supposed to know when
some girls change their mind i agree
some girls want to be like they do
play hard to get
but that's wrong though so like
i
obviously yes like let your no be a no
and i think just in life like a no is a
no so if someone says no okay i will
take the no brother i like you saying no
or not i have to accept that because
that was your answer
i have i have two more examples yeah
so the first one i think i forgot the
second one but the first one here is
what about being intoxicated yeah you
could be so intoxicated that you
physically cannot give consent but you
still end up having sex yeah that's my
first example my second example is yeah
is say for instance here you two are
together yeah and i don't know it's
early on in the relationship and you
haven't discussed yeah
how you might feel if he wakes you up
with a bit of dick but then one morning
you wake up and you've got a dick inside
you is that rape
great that is that is yeah it is oh yeah
because you haven't discussed that
you're cool with that yet
i don't think it's great if you do
something because you you feel bad or
you feel like you have to is it is it
i'm not asking that much 100 hit me up
the example was that uh you're in a
relationship something you haven't
really discussed yeah does it become
great
irrespective or is it only if she
doesn't like it oh she says no i didn't
i didn't consent to that if i'm asleep
how can i
like because equally if it was the
reverse and and yeah yeah i know
it was a reverse and the guy's sleeping
and she wants to give him head to wake
him up
it's like it's that there's a there's a
blurred line
and that's where the loop is
no but i think i think it's it's wrong
either way like i don't care no but no
but i feel like because we're in this
discussion now you you're saying no it's
wrong no but in reality just in general
like just just society people wouldn't
think that's wrong yes it's like
now
[Music]
so you're saying that just because i go
to someone's house like if i go or they
come to mind that means we're
automatically having sex
i shouldn't be obligated to have sex
doesn't it doesn't mean you're obligated
but what i'm saying is like
it's like
like you can kick him out you can tell
him to leave and if you if he's the type
of guy you would be scared with he
shouldn't be at your apartment but
people can change people can't yeah
people can be people but i don't think i
think that's the exception rather than
the rules i don't think most men are
like that
but some some people are predators as
well
yeah i know but again we're picking the
extreme guy like most guys i've i've had
guys at my like apartment and i didn't
sleep with them and most guys if you
tell them no they'll they'll listen i
think your point is even if they are a
predator like so what you are still able
to sort of say yes or no yeah
yeah i do this kind of and i don't think
it's like oh i think he might great me
so sleep with him like that doesn't
always i think that men should
definitely understand to like um not
manipulate women in a certain way
but i i think yeah no but i think that
women have to understand that some men
can't control themselves in it if you if
if a woman agrees to come back to a
man's crib yeah understand that not all
men can control themselves if they have
a woman there because they might not
have a woman therefore yeah she's great
so yeah should i tell you something here
um
there was this guy
and
i thought we were friends
and um
like but i don't know he was just he's
just a bit weird
and then it's like um
one time i went to his house i've heard
bear stories like this and i said to him
like you know like we're cool whatever
whatever whatever whatever like he was
all right and then um
when i was leaving i was like let me eat
a pursuit
i don't know i was like what but it's
like he kept on kept on kept on asking
me and i thought no no i need to leave
now
so i've left now
and then like he he's messaging me oh
like
you're a queen you're this you're i want
to marry you
xyz and i'm just like look i don't want
to be nasty in it like i've already told
him that like i don't like you like that
in it like i think we should just be
friends
and he even said like rola i i can't be
your friend in it because i can't i
can't control myself
some people say and it doesn't surprise
me because you're [ __ ] weirdo
yeah but it sounds like yeah he did
control himself no he didn't i left no
but that's like right it wasn't like he
grabbed you or anything technically he
did control him yeah technically he did
it he didn't he didn't he didn't fam
yeah because he knew before i even went
there he knew we are friends yeah i've
gone there to do content with him do you
understand so if i've come here under of
under the guise that we're doing content
you shouldn't then be saying you
shouldn't be then making me feel
uncomfortable putting me on the spot
asking to do these sexual things to me
and then once i've said no you're still
persistent to ask me that's not
controlling yourself see that's more
context because at first it was like you
just went over there okay there's the
context you're going there for a
specific reason and it's nothing to do
with sexual stuff
then that's that's [ __ ] up like yeah
yeah
no but even so sometimes even when guys
can't differentiate what not what
what they're going to get yeah they
can't differentiate what's playing hard
to get and what's
what's actually you know sometimes you
have to okay i don't want to say bring
one bro but i'm saying sometimes you
have to understand women yeah let's say
i'm using social media since
because that's what young people look at
most of the time yeah and the whole
narrative is oh
like i love playing hard to get it
very rare
it's because it blurs the line it's so
cool a lot of young guys you know i mean
yeah but we sent a full girl once sex so
she's not going to be manipulative
sometimes to go back getting it like
yeah
i mean she will be she will be but then
playing hard to get and actually like
saying no it's a very thin line it's a
feeling the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested anyone now the difference is
when you just know like no you're in the
moment let's say for example no because
women will go on dates even if they're
not interested in the guy yeah so you
can't know
i've also seen girls like i've also seen
girls
be all up like over a guy and like even
like we're in like you know a party type
environment i'm thinking she's like
bringing him to bringing him back you
know and then she'll like like turn
around be like oh my god he's so creepy
i'm like what you're all over him yes
and i'm like i see stuff like that i'm
like she wants his non-sexual attention
yeah i mean no i'm not interested in you
and the guy's like you know she wants me
still like she's she just doesn't know
him no
listen the lines are so blurred and pete
i was i was mid
pump
okay and the girl was like stop
like stop repeatedly and i was like oh
[ __ ] and i stopped and she was like
you're not actually supposed to stop why
are you stopping
you know
you can stop yeah a lot of men out there
i'll even say more than half a man out
there he can't control himself i can't
stop you
like that's that's [ __ ] because i've
had lots of times i'm stopping i just
know why are you stopping and it's not
even why you're stopping it's like oh
what a [ __ ] why are you stopping
yeah [ __ ] all right you got me and it's
like and i'm like yo rape is is a strong
thing if i could stop i'm sorry
grapefruit i just think it's like i'm
just big into like accountability yeah
yeah so like i think a lot of times like
i've been in situations where i'm like
well i shouldn't have put myself in that
situation some people would like it like
yeah
i've been in a place where i thought the
guy like might be trying to like i was
going somewhere for content i just
always bring a third person
if it's a dude and like i've never
really met him like i'm bringing a third
person no i've met him before
and he was friends with my cousin oh
okay so yeah i knew him through friends
so i didn't really feel like it needed
to be like that
but then when he actually said like
you're not like i can't be friends with
girls i can't control myself i
definitely understood why
i think
i think at any blurred lines you should
remove yourself so whether it's a a
female or a male whatever yeah like if
you are confused that's your answer that
means no like you should never you
should be certain
with what whatever you're doing like
like especially sex like
i get that it's like that can be cute
for some people but
me personally i couldn't see myself
being turned on like well i won't say
that but
i i think as a person like you should
say
maybe they're going to come back later
and say they didn't want to do this why
would i want to continue knowing that
they could possibly rather it's true or
not if i know that they could be like
like if they're wishy-washy in the
situation why would i put myself in
there so like
if you don't know the signs aren't easy
to read well that's what it does yeah
but so if it's not easy to read that
should just be a no when i say not easy
to read in the sense that what i'm
reading is you do want it so it's not
easy to read that you don't that's what
i'm saying you just don't [ __ ] with
people that you don't trust that's what
i'm saying you will trust if you've been
in like 10 days your mom i trust this
person do you know i mean i don't care
but you can change at any in any second
so how you're saying like you're like
mid-pump and the girl's like saying stop
so once she says that i like okay i will
stop and like if you say oh i'm just
playing no i'm not playing with you you
you can be playing you go [ __ ] off
because i'm not playing with you so like
no
yes or yes like i'm not gonna be in the
middle like oh why says stop and then i
said yeah you can come again and then i
said stop again like i didn't really
mean come again no it once when
someone's saying no that's it bye
bye and i think that's just how it
should be like you should never be in a
position to where if it isn't true to
where they can be like oh yeah you did
you understand how it's confusing for
men i get it and people are [ __ ] yeah
but that's why i'm saying like if it's
if you're confused that's your answer no
that means no
it should be a certain yes somebody i
don't think girls should i don't think
girls should be able to like press
charges or like go to the place for
coercion
i don't like i think there's a
difference between like you
like you might and i i understand it
like i'm sort of a people pleaser so i i
understand i hate pushy guys like that
it's so unattractive to me like if i
tell you no and you won't leave me alone
about it but like i don't think you
should be able to go to the police just
because you changed your mind or yeah
but it's different into something
there's different levels to coerce and
it could be courage and where it's just
like you said you you know you moved to
a little bit more or there's this guy's
intimidating and i'm scared that he's
going to beat me up who's going to do so
he's going to rape me anyway i'm just
great i'm just i'm just a big believer
in like accountability like vet the guys
that you you vet them yeah like exactly
like like you are what you attract so if
you keep picking guys like this there's
something about you
and like like you you should be
responsible for the people that you
bring into your i say about the second
date max you know like what kind of
person this is do you know what can i
say you see in the day and age that we
kind of live in here everything right
now is about lifestyle yeah so you see
sometimes your girls then they're not
interested in vetting the guys they're
just interested
in me to hackathon are you taking me to
sexy fish yeah but you see yeah what
these young girls need to understand
here is when you're going out with these
men and you're allowing these men to
spend all of these money all of this
money on you some of these men are
looking for a return on their investment
facts is true it's not right but it's
true it's not right
no i don't know it's true but that's why
i'm saying i don't mind paying for my
own [ __ ] because i i don't like
i don't want anyone saying oh i expect
this from you no you don't
you see some of these young
impressionable women as well after a man
has spent all of this money on her she
feels indebted it's not even because she
wants to do she actually
that's what the exchange is it's a man's
time attention and resources and change
for exchange for sexual access so you
keep accepting [ __ ] from dudes like i
think at some point you should probably
sleep with them or cut it off yeah yeah
like it's not like why are we playing
these games like we don't we don't know
what we do
we know what the exchange is like you
can't go blindly into a date yeah with a
guy like you're spending racks on you or
whatever you spent like two like let's
say three four bills on dinner and you
expect him to not sleep with jesus
no i'm not saying this right but i'm
saying have that impression that you
think that he wants to sleep with you
yeah because look at the exchange it's a
clear exchange you know what i mean but
then this is why yeah sometimes as well
yeah like i like i like to be friends
with people
and um i kind of try to set the
precedent so it's that you see like if i
i have i don't really have girlfriends
most of my friends are male
like most of them
and but when i'm making that new
friendships or whatever they just want
to sleep with you yeah
my friends don't want to sleep because
[ __ ]
right now
i'm sorry i'm sorry why not if they
don't want to sleep
one at a time
right now call
no wait i don't know
call him and say what tell him okay so
say
that you are tell him you're you're
horny
[Music]
obviously they're gonna lap it
up yeah but what i'm trying to say to
you is you seem like my friend shared a
boy like they look out for me yeah they
don't expect nothing in return for me
what do you mean until it's their turn
these are my friends that i've been
friends that i've been friends with for
years
it's not that they're not friends
they're probably loyal to you to the
core yeah but if they had the
opportunity that's just all it is yeah
yeah but they're probably your boys like
that like they probably got you back but
that's why i i i don't know you're the
opposite sex like and if you're lying
obviously you might be my brethren but
if men have that little window to they
think oh they're there there's a few men
that won't though yeah just out of
respect do you understand that you see
like one of my brothers one of my
brothers got nine sisters yeah so he
respects women yeah he i i can't swear
for no one yeah but i'm hoping yeah that
he respects our relationship so much
that he wouldn't want to try and ruin it
i know how he is i he knows how i am he
knows you're hoping like call him call
him right now say you're say you're
horny
say you're horny and you have to
confront him
because he'll do it i
i can't shame him like that because he's
my brethren i love him in it and i'm not
going to do that to him
but i that's why i don't think that um
that men and women can be actually like
friends because guys don't see women
like as actual people so i disagree
right no i feel like as a guy you can
find your fear my friends attractive
yeah just because you find them
attractive it doesn't mean you have to
be a dick and act on it right yeah
you're gonna clean the dick if you act
on it but the difference is if the
window's there yeah but if she's showing
you yeah but okay like
you it's not like man would be like no
no i can't you're my friend no no
lucky man will actually
yeah because see they were waiting for
that moment that whole time so they
weren't actually wanting to be friends
they were wanting to pass no no no no no
they they really love them legit friends
they really love you as a friend but we
know as men you we know you're sexy so
if we find that window to just that
window you show us that window we're
there like my friends they know
i really want to go okay
let me tell you something
right now would you go right now if i
was yeah if i was saying would you go
right now
you've seen my pregnancy
though
i wouldn't because i value our
friendship john's saying i think you're
fired up but like i have value our
friendships i wouldn't do that take a
coffee okay
you see my budget yet they know yeah
that i'm just nice to look at nothing
more you understand you don't want this
headache you don't want this problem
they know that they leave me alone
they've never they've never ever crossed
the land they've never made me feel
uncomfortable but they've never done
nothing they might not want to date you
but i think if you if you
if they won't fall into this if i gave
my british opportunity they'd probably
marry me
so they wouldn't date you but they'll
marry they'll marry me aren't you okay
so but obviously obviously we wouldn't
wanna we wouldn't wanna cross that
boundaries because you see once i get
into i'm a very i'm a very toxic person
and that can be very
i could know toxic i can be very
disrespectful and you see the way her
i'm with man sometimes i wouldn't want
to treat my bridges like that because
you know what when i'm going through
whatever i'm going through they're the
ones that are there for me they're the
ones
they don't deserve it they you see me
at the front of your bridge
i'm gonna read super chats real quick oh
god we're gonna get crossed again
[Laughter]
will you um also i i try to just get
through them quick so please don't
respond yeah please
just as quick as you can
okay so
um oh shoot sorry guys i have a new
the touch screen is kind of throwing me
off okay
so what was the last one i read do you
remember
um
no she had already read that no okay i
think i think it was either this one so
just human 20 um if you engage with
violence you sign up for whatever comes
next if you slap a person and they go
bat and you pull up with a strap that's
the game anytime you choose to fight
your life is on the line i think that
was the last one so then van
zago johnson pearl you are my new
favorite show to watch thank you
um
keep up what you're doing megan lied
amber should go to jail crazy laugh is
maybe really crazy
um twenty dollars from corty jones
according to the centers for disease
control uh and prevention lesbian gay
and bisexual people experience sexual
violence at a similar or higher rates
than straight people sentience 50
uh
okay um i will not justify myself to
your feelings regarding my last comments
i said what i said also that grape study
was based on a questionnaire that asked
what that this was what it was that
study asked if a woman felt unsafe or
other vague terms that lumped in the
whole study many um
according to the u.s state reported
stats in 2020 there are 838 forcible
grapes per 100 000 people please work
research where the sound bites you're
saying are coming from that study that
study i mentioned by about one in five
was done by kate moss only at one
university
ninja watchers626 that madam needs to
read the rap that
madam needs to read the rational male
pearl game these dudes honest citizens
many women reject
men who reject men do so disrespectfully
others bragged to their friends about
the guy they rejected the more guys they
reject the more her beauty is validated
among her peers um just human 10 10
what do you mean by coercion coercion is
manipulation under the threat of
violence you ladies have agency these
are situations you want to feel
empowered and stand up for yourselves
just human new male friends aren't
paying for your dinner without asking
for anything in return either you go go
either you got them
next meal or you're on a date and then i
think there was some let me just refresh
the chat and get the last ones
um
bro brooke escalator pearl please
explain into the
wait pearl please explain to the lady in
the middle what anecdotal evidence is
and to add
qual quality to this conversations like
this to her limited life experiences let
your experiences virtually inconsistent
stick to stats
[Music]
triggers come on fat kelsey
kelsey mexican oh oh
no i agree with the um
with the fact that women
women feel empowered when they reject
men
and they do it disrespectfully is mad
and i'll be honest yeah it's like we're
not not sorry not every woman yeah but
i've seen something
like if there goes around you it's like
yeah mm-hmm yeah no i can't actually i
can't imagine
smashing yeah i'm not rejecting i can't
imagine a guy being moved to the whole
night and and disrespectfully turning no
no but you like the idea of people being
interested no no yeah but the comment
was like
women the girl won't go for it but the
guy obviously will yeah the woman and in
the rejection should be honest yeah like
i skipped a super chat they're saying i
skipped a super chat
when when i take like women out on dates
like it depends on look on the girls
but um
i'm like there was a super chat there
that discussed like the exchange of
dates with sleeping with women or just
taking them back home like
there's nothing wrong with suggesting do
you want to come back to mine do you
know what i mean because
like why not yeah be a man if the vibe
you've got booze bro like ask the girl
do you want to come back tomorrow yeah
yeah i mean she says no if she says no
cool you can go on a second date and
then i'm not going to ask you again but
if you suggest it through your vibes and
whatnot you can do that but if it's that
deep if it offended her that you'd ask
her like there wouldn't be yeah yeah and
my thing is it's like obviously that's
that that example that i'm giving of how
that i would ask some women to come back
to mind it's like women have to
understand that there's there's a clear
exchange going on i mean i'm investing
in your stocks to come back yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean so exactly
yeah that's a clear understanding it's
not even that i think it's before the
day you know when you're chatting to
when you're both chatting yeah you know
if if you're on him or if you're on her
journey
way before the day
before the exchange of the tension
builds up yeah like you know if you want
to have sex with each other or not yeah
and in the day i feel like the date just
confirms it yeah to see how it goes yeah
you know what i mean i think you should
like say oh like
do you want to engage sexually like just
to make it clearer
because it won't if you're saying like
if you're both making it clear yes i
would like to engage sexually then
neither one of you can say oh i felt
this way or i felt me i played it
on the date no before her i feel like to
me yeah i feel like bro that is so
unnatural nah do you know what you can
do in a way that's natural you can know
before going on a date
if she's if she's okay if she's dominant
yeah this is this is what i think i
think if i if i'm okay i bring a guy
back to my place
and we're going into my room like you
you need to ask for my consent
every step okay can i take this step oh
can i take the next thing
what the [ __ ] yeah i just think it's
like common sense like if i'm bringing a
dude back to my place but there are
women who would say even if i'm laying
in bed next to you naked oh don't get me
wrong you could still say
no but like then
like i don't need you to i'll tell you
like i'll
i'll let you know
i'm not saying consent is bad but i'm
saying like obviously things happen
naturally and the way we're built is
just natural like we feed off energies
you know what i mean so you said a
consent is implied right yeah by the
vibe you're like well she didn't say no
she didn't say yes bro
so i just think here that you see like
in my experiences which are not
statistical
whatever that like i've been on like
dates and then i've been invited back to
people's houses or whatever
and if i feel like oh the night is young
i'm not ready to go home but i would say
to me i'll come back to us i'm not
having sex with you though like it's not
a sex thing i mean i'll put that out
there very early on like yeah we can
come we can fight but when it's time for
me to go home i'm getting an uber mm-hmm
do you understand that i'm not even even
that even that is not risky but even
that
there's always going to be hope because
the guy is going to be or even the girl
might be like ah the wind can change
that means it might change your mind
anything can change so but this is it
though because if i come back to your
house here on the pretense of like not
in a pretext but like on that that you
know like yeah we're gonna come and vibe
we're gonna continue to party like i'm
not even coming to your bedroom yeah but
you can you can have sex in a car like
bedroom
no i feel like subconsciously if you're
going back to a man's yard
there's a slight chance it's so i'm
saying
okay this is gonna be the second thing
that i said now yeah all right so i i
was um seeing some guy and um but
i i was seeing him for quite a while
before we had sex like
10 11 months
[Music]
and then i basically had to say
did you like make it clear or like
how did you guys go that long without
having sex like he should be having sex
with other people yeah she has to um
know each other like you're just getting
to know each other and then i feel like
when like
we talked about quite a lot of time i
used to stay at his house i used to
sleep in a bed with him he wouldn't
touch me he would stay at my house like
like when i was vulnerable when i'm
going through my my bipolar phases or
whatever he'd call me just chill with me
just to beat over that just to hold me
or whatever like he wouldn't touch me
wouldn't be inappropriate or nothing
and then
i stayed at his house one night
again slept in the bed with him did not
touch me
and let's test it from now what are you
gay
[Music]
[Laughter]
so have you ever slept with a guy like
really quick yeah so what why did you
make that guy wait because he's a man
you move like a man
well i promise you there's certain
things about him
i asked her the question no i know i
know but there's certain things about
him that make you want to sleep with him
on the first or second night that you've
seen him i promise you sometimes you're
my man you're linking for 10 11 months
yeah god's outside
i'm gonna answer now yeah
so one guy i had sex with him fairly
quickly
and it was because it was a challenge
yeah
what do you set yourself to challenge
yeah i just have myself a challenge
because he was very like egotistical he
would always oh i'm gonna just get i'm
setting myself up for failure right now
but he would be like oh like like for me
like the way how he carried himself here
like with this person in particular i
didn't care about the before sex
treatment i needed to see how he was
gonna treat me after the sex
i had to give it to him fairly quickly
just to know that i've got it like that
and then
then he was at how's that
wait wait so so you you just wanted to
see how he'd treat you after you slept
together
yeah
how'd it go you treat me very well okay
so because he's like because he okay so
basically yeah like he like i said she's
very egotistical
so like before me even having sex with
him whatever like i would hear how he
speaks to his friends oh if girls
pussy's trash this this this and that so
i'd say to myself okay then so where am
i gonna where am i gonna be on this
chart am i gonna be up here or am i
gonna be
rank yourself with him i wanted to rank
myself with him
and then when i ranked myself with him i
was like
up here like all the way up here this
guy's thinking that he's a genius right
now like
yeah
really quickly yeah what do you need to
say is that you're up here and that's it
my man the difference between that guy
and my man he's looking for 10 11 months
yeah
he was a nice guy no no no no no no no
no let me know
like that let me tell you he was a [ __ ]
boy a hundred percent he was like yeah
and
those are the guys are clean or not you
see the
the nice guy the nice guy i didn't sleep
with him not because i didn't want to
because from i met him that there were
sparks there was connection there was
chemistry there was attraction
but
unfortunately
i was kind of seeing somebody else i
know i do you know what i think it was
yeah can i be sorry to interrupt you but
i think it's because you saw the spark
the connections and whatnot so you saw
it more as a as a husband or a hubby or
a partner or whatnot he is mr nice guy
but [ __ ] boy mr fuckboy because you was
trying to prove yourself to him and
whatnot and he was mr mysterious and you
was trying to rank yourself he was more
of a chinese youth that's why i said i i
accepted the
challenge you asked him what is he going
with no no but with this guy here yeah
that are you gay guy yeah it's like um
i knew from the jump yeah do you know
what it's not even that as well i knew
from the jumpers right here that if me
and you start [ __ ] each other it's
going to get toxic it's going to get so
toxic and i don't know if i'm ready for
that
why would he get toxic you would bully
him
i tried to i think you would wouldn't
i don't think i don't think he'd have it
i tried some men play the longer he does
have it sometimes and then when he's
ready to switch and tell me about the
block like i'm like i can't believe you
spoke that's what i'm saying
there's nice guys and this man that will
play the long game they'll just be
friends like
i'm gonna be your friend but i know i'm
gonna beat but i know i'm going to have
you you know what i mean yeah the [ __ ]
boy can beat quicker
you feel me you're going to call me when
you need anything so i've got you
regardless yeah and even even on top of
that
like not moving to her she's going to be
thinking why is he not moving to me yeah
like every man is on me why she's not
trying to say so some might know that
they will play that game the longest
yeah and they'll start making you feel
like
but mr [ __ ] boy he ain't got time to do
the long run because he's got a million
other girls that he's lingering
but who would you rather be though if
like what it depends on what you're
making nice guys
someone for 10 minutes
i'm trying to wipe these ten
miles i don't think yeah he is mr nice
guy i just think yeah that like you see
it's different strokes with different
folks in there some people have got a
higher level of respect
for you than other people in it and that
for instance share that even that me and
him here like even when that he pisses
me off yeah
i could say to him about cool yeah like
come to my house and he'll come and i'll
say some okay but you're sleeping on the
sofa
but just for the fact that he's there
with me like do you know what i mean the
security well there's there's like
traits like between like that girls look
for that tend to be
that are in action you know if you are a
convicted
like convicted of a crime you're more
likely to reproduce not less likely as a
guy no way
yeah you're convicted of a crime yeah
it's because it's like that bad boy
thing yeah it's because the traits
the traits that make that traits that
make a man the hero also makes the man
the villain yeah so so for example like
aggression the hero in the story has to
be aggressive yeah but so does
um so does the villain yeah right
because obviously women like that sense
of security
you know i mean like a guy that's been
arrested or being a felon or whatnot
like that shows that he he lives on the
wild side sometimes you know i mean
so some girls like their men in jail
because they know where they are
okay not to keep going back to this but
so this time that yous were like you
know seeing each other for 10 11 months
and not doing anything did you not kiss
her anything like
who is my man rob i could do that easy
he would kiss me like on my cheek and on
my forehead and that just kind of like
maybe you fall in love with him
see what she said that made me fall and
love him this guy is playing the long
game he's smart robot he's not a nice
guy as in oh i'm too he's manipulative
smart that's what i'm saying bro that's
manipulation
he's manipulative and that's true
about his manipulation some guys know
but he doesn't
yeah
but she already said that she's talking
[Laughter]
for those 10 11 months he knew exactly
what he knew he was doing yeah
and then my ex is going to be watching
this like what guy was you seeing
i think i played you not joking
me too
[Laughter]
um okay so
so you're not still seeing that guy the
10 11 months it sounds like she is
she is
she is
she is he's now he's in the picture no
you might not be seeing it maybe if he
flies me out maybe we get back together
yo
mr turn 11 months you're being played
bro he's not being probably ain't being
played he knows what he's doing he knows
what he's doing he's not being played
but
like he's being
he knows what he's doing
i think if you're making a man's time
attention and resources and giving
nothing in return he doesn't get nothing
kimberton what does he get in return you
should spend time with her yeah oh my
god bro
do you guys think it's okay like vice
versa for a dude to sleep with a girl
like that he knows that she like likes
him wants something more but he's never
going to give it to her
as long as he as long as he's clear that
i'm not really looking for anything else
okay i've told you no but i think in
that instance he's not i'll sleep we've
got they've told me that they want to be
well then i asked the girls one second
oh right yeah so what'd you what do you
guys think
i don't i don't see myself like fancying
a guy that doesn't like me okay no he
likes you but no but i'm i'm asking if
you think it's wrong i think you sleep
with a girl
likes her but she's like weak for him i
think it's wrong i think it's wrong i
think yeah it is probably wrong but then
also it's just like how you're saying
like you choose to sleep with these
people okay like you knew that he didn't
like you yeah so no but sometimes you
don't really know when they're no you
know if someone likes you or not no no
no no this is what i think yeah like you
see sometimes yeah when a guy knows that
a girl
is infatuated with them they take
advantage of that because they know that
that's the weak spot they take advantage
of that and that's exploitation and that
is wrong but you don't think you don't
think you were
but
wait wait you don't you don't think that
you were taking advantage of a guy for
10 11 months i wasn't taking a flight
into a family but if he's choosing to
spend all this time with you you're not
giving him
any i don't think that's taking
advantage he didn't want nothing
returned
he didn't want anything in return
he did like i said he didn't try
anything on me and i didn't reject him
like he was just being respectful i was
going through things and he didn't try
and take advantage of my phone for me he
was being respectful okay
why do you think that that would make
her like taking advantage of him because
it seems like like they're both going
along with it like that's almost a year
i don't think you're obligated to have
sex with someone like i don't think
you're obligated to but it's it's more
like the principle like if if like
clearly he wants to sleep with you i
don't think like we play these games
like like oh he doesn't he like come on
how can i add to that yeah because i
feel like whilst he was linking him to
10 11 months he was probably sleeping
with other people but you was using him
for your non-sexual attention no i don't
even think it's because obviously you're
using it for comfort in a non-sexual way
i wasn't sleeping with people thing is
can you can you really compare it like
is it bigger but the thing is yeah but
the thing is what can you compare what
as in like you're going to have a guy
who knows that a girl's into him yeah
but he's just like leaving that's the
equivalent like the like i think that's
like the equivalent of taking a guy's
time attention and resources and giving
nothing in return what is she taking
from if he does sleep with her
is it the same as a guy because if a guy
sleeps with a girl uh-huh and he's that
friend zone guy i'm hearing me
celebrating that i just got to see her
that's not the same reaction for the
girl the girl's going to have a probably
a different reaction
she's thinking oh maybe he actually
wants to be with me or something yeah
yeah and so it's like
it's the same action but yeah that's
it's the same i think it's the same but
opposite yeah the feeling is a lot so
different like y'all's probably more
emotionally invested whereas that guy
i don't know if he's wanting to think if
he's emotionally invested if he spent 10
11 months
i don't think so i think if if it's a
guy that's running game he don't it
doesn't bother him
his desire in that situation is to be a
friend so he's not lacking he's
fulfilling all his desires and i can get
a letter to come into my yard sleep in
my bed
we're actually getting to know each
other but quicker than if we were going
on dates and going to the streets you
know
and she's keeping them off like yeah if
that was the case
but i feel like if
i can see you guys doing that and just
feeling comfortable yeah i think yeah at
that point it's just a mutual thing
because like that's just like shocking
to me like i i can i can go without
having sex like i don't think sex is
everything but if you're spending this
much time with someone and no i don't
think so like that's not the premise of
the relationship but
like if you're spending time with
someone and it's like
we like each other um
more than just platonically yeah um
and at some point like we're gonna kiss
so if we're kissing and you know you're
how does it not like
yeah
but it depends on the game plan that's
what if you i don't care what game plan
maybe i am playing the wrong game
because
if you have a game plan going into it i
can see you guys doing that with 10
girls on it's not a thing you get me
because in my mind i'm trying to acquire
girls that i'm that's going to be in my
life for the long term
and i know at any point i've got their
heart whoever they're [ __ ] with is
just [ __ ] no but that's yeah oh you
don't though
are you down
now i'm telling you i'm telling you i
know what you mean
i'm telling you i do get what you're
saying yeah but also like you don't gain
their heart because they don't genuinely
like want you you're like their backup
plan all right imagine okay imagine
imagine anthony joshua okay he kind of
has that personality like he's a nice
guy yeah i don't know
the boxer the guy who [ __ ] people up
he's a nice guy yeah yeah
nice guy
anthony joshua no he's a nice guy yeah i
don't know he could play that one he can
play that game you can see him playing
that game bro now you can see him dating
a girl not even wanting to beat and just
chilling for months really
yeah
no i don't know i don't know what i'm
saying but they don't
they don't lose respect for him they
don't look at him as a waste man he's
it's like yeah he's hot like in their
minds you feel me so it's not
necessarily that they're they're using
them or they don't respect him there's
guys who
there's guys who who win at that game
i'm telling you i can't lie to you i
feel like my guys have played a long run
they're not that respected
no
that's what if a girl really likes you
she won't i don't think she'll make you
wait that way
i really really liked him yeah but do
you know what it is yeah like i said i
was in a vulnerable space and i just
felt like all right cool if i'm going to
give myself to you i want to make sure
that like i want to get to know you as
much as i can like i don't want to end
up giving myself to you and then
regretting it after yeah i think yeah
that's why i say a a woman respects a
man that she slept with in a quicker in
a short time
let me tell you no do you know why
because i feel like women respect that
are very masculine that's what i mean it
depends on whether you're a very
feminine woman so i feel like in that in
that instance now men that are very
masculine they want to wait 10 11 months
they would want to get a cracking sooner
than that most men yeah
yeah you see him i have absolutely no
respect for him that's what i'm saying
but to you you see absolutely for me it
was a challenge i just i just wanted to
know
if i could i just wanted to know if i
could suck you in that room that guy was
nothing and i just wanted to know if i
could suck you in and i could suck you
in and that's that's all it was like i
don't have any respect for him
whatsoever but it's like the way a girl
because i feel like there's two types of
like got like and i hate i hate the
manosphere terms but i think there's
like the guy that a girl views as more
like alpha and that's like the guy she
wants to like be with and then there's
the beta she keeps on the side in case
that doesn't work out and like you're
not with that guy today where is he
where is he the 10 month 11 month he
said you're not be seeing him often you
just told me you weren't with him
earlier oh yeah not with him that's what
i'm saying that's why i'm saying what's
the game at the beginning if the game is
not to be together then there's nothing
wrong with it if if the game's not to be
together even though they're not
together now there's nothing
no one
was out abbey rule yeah um
i have temper tantrums
i do i
and i had i had i had a temper tantrum
last week
so because i had a temper tantrum like i
blocked him and everything
okay he's definitely been unblocked by
now
good for you i just
i need
yeah
i'm just i'm weird didn't it and um like
i need something yeah
before i can go back
what you're what you're seeing what
you're seeing is that this guy's not an
alpha because it's been 11 months or
whatever but he could that's why i said
anthony joshua he's like he's a built
boxes like six foot whatever yeah this
guy's an out you can be an alpha and be
patient and wait 12 months like that's
nothing i don't know because
it's cool
it's not alpha or beta though it's like
how does that girl view you
it's how does the girl that's what i'm
saying
like so she has to view you as like the
best she can do
and i don't think a girl like i don't
think most of the time you might be the
exception but i don't think most of the
time a girl's gonna make you wait if
like you are it for her like she like
she like that she has that feeling where
like you have everything she wants like
she's making you wait like she's trying
to figure out her butts like like what's
your butt she's still trying to figure
out her options
yeah i think i think you're right
because like
as people we know like from meeting
someone
what you can go off of like it doesn't
take you that long to figure out if i
want to [ __ ] this person or not
when would you have slept because you
said to him are you gay that means that
you wanted it already and you he's
second to none no no no no no not
necessarily she wanted it that was
towards that was that okay so let me
give you a little bit more contextual
when when i met him
we was just like you just get to talk
with a friend and i already had a
boyfriend how did you meet that's what
i'm saying that's the key thing she
already said i am just friends i'm not
it doesn't matter she was with someone
who's one of them i'm never gonna have
sex with you i had a boyfriend
and um it was quite toxic and um we were
on and off
so when we were off i would i would talk
to him quite a lot like i'd see him like
whatever but
he knew that you know that i've got the
situation i'm a bit vulnerable like he
didn't try to force it onto me
and for me what it is of him why i
respect him is because i know yeah that
when he sees me he sees more than sex in
it
i'm i'm content with that i'm happy with
that it's not a disrespectful thing i
know that at the end of the day that
it's not your be you and your angel just
to [ __ ] me in it
so wait question so you were with your
boyfriend when you met him your
ex-boyfriend and then when you were off
would you get back on with your
boyfriend like in between
so then wouldn't your boyfriend be the
first choice in that case
because that's who you chose over him
okay so basically okay so basically like
but this is it we were people just
friends we were just getting to know
each other yeah i had a situation so
it's like even like when we were like if
i found like about cool i might go back
to my boyfriend or
whatever whatever whatever i would say
to him that rola you know like i think
it's a bit inappropriate but you know
what i mean that but you know what i'm
definitely going to if anything if i'm
in a position i will spin the block for
you i'm definitely going to be spinning
the block for you
so if that being said as well like i
don't even know in the back of my mind
if i was thinking to myself like i'm
waiting for the relationship that i'm in
to full to [ __ ] so i can go and be with
this guy
so you had him as like a backup plan he
wasn't a backup player it's not even
about it it's hard to say it's not a
backup he was just there in it he was
just there when i needed him period
yeah but i'm not saying a backup plan is
like a it's like something any [ __ ]
but a backup plan is that definitional
like what she's saying
yeah i mean someone you can fall back on
when no guy goes to [ __ ] no i don't even
think so do you know who i am do you
know like that's what i was going to say
[Music]
yeah you don't even want to see using my
views and madiums
raw so
now i think the temple guy no he knows
what he's saying but i think that is
different like in context because that's
different than you saying yeah like i've
been talking to this guy for 10 11
months versus i was in and out of a
relationship and also entertaining
someone else
but it wasn't it's not entertaining it's
building a friendship
and there's nothing there's nothing
sexual going on that's what i'm saying
you don't think that's [ __ ] no no no
don't get me wrong that just sounds
really shady no it is it is it is for it
is for the partner in in that situation
i would be pissed oh my god if that
happened to me i would be pissed if like
and you would be too if your
ex-boyfriend had a girl that's about my
expert [ __ ] though he's a good person
he's good as a friend but he's not he
wasn't a good boyfriend
yeah but like it doesn't make it okay to
like do that but you know what he was he
was doing things that was much worse
than what i was doing what house huh
house
more than hers mm-hmm
more than you like that sometimes
people can say it's right and people say
it's wrong
all i care about is what's right for me
and
um fair enough it comes down to some of
the guys winning bro i think we've
spoken about trust more about tim
off-guard than we have about megan
[Laughter]
i was just thinking how can i wrap this
back up
in the
[Laughter]
okay going back to the megan the
stallion tory lanez i feel like they've
kind of made it like a woman issue where
she's like we have to believe women do
you guys feel like that
no i think believe whoever's telling the
truth and
no i meant like do you feel like she has
done that
like protect women
what i feel like a lot of people are
victims shamed her true her victim shame
yeah she hasn't had it easy she hasn't
had it smooth as unbelievable women
uh-huh from the from the jumps right a
lot of people believe that but then a
lot of people victim blamed her so it's
like how is it victim blaming if you're
saying i don't think you're telling the
truth
i don't think that's what i don't think
it was a straight i don't think you're
telling the truth i think it was
i don't think it was i don't think
you're telling the truth based on what
you're saying it was i don't think it's
an improved period just because it
sounds wacky yeah and then now it's i
don't think you're telling the truth
because she's made a public statement on
with gail king or whatever it is and she
just looks like she was lying in summer
well yeah i mean i think like i have a
whole page of like notes and [ __ ] that
was inconsistent yeah and so she did two
lives in the beginning and even the
lives the stories weren't the same yeah
oh wow so i'm saying like like i don't
think it's how is it victim shaming if
you you just sound like you're lying i
think it's easy to say victim shaming no
i'm asking you because you said it right
oh you're asking me yeah
the reason why i say yeah that i feel
like she's victim changes because like
even that quiet at the beginning because
it's happened like what two years ago
yeah two years ago
um when it happened and she was coming
and telling her story a lot of people in
the comments are blaming her so that is
in a sense victim chairman yeah how are
they blaming her what were they saying
i can't remember it was two years ago oh
okay yeah i can't remember
i do you remember she was being victim
changed yeah so before the
inconsistencies
from the from the jump she was being out
attacked
victim yeah i can't remember what was
said so i can't clarify i think it could
be a bit different because um
people have
before like before this incident right
it's like oh she's transgender
and like
no megan
there's been a lot of gender no no no
no no no there have been a lot of like
people like oh she's not she's not a
woman she's she's a man she's masculine
she's not really a woman she's a trans
woman blah blah blah or whatever well
that comes with the comment like people
people say that i'm ugly every day like
no no no no no
no no i get like i even get like she's
too masculine she's a four like i that
that comes with just being on the
internet if you don't like it don't be
on the internet no it's not about being
on the internet it's like just like say
you're seeing her oh like yeah that's a
man or whatever yeah so i think it is a
bit different um with like people not
believe in her because they're already
not viewing her as a woman
even though she is i think they i just
don't
like it seemed like at first
people were on her side to be honest and
even now if i google it in the media
like all of the first articles that come
up are like very much like pro
megan the stallion as well even though
even though the new evidence like isn't
supportive of her
so
i i just think like on the internet of
course you're gonna get mixed sides but
it's not really victim shaming i would
say the vibe for like the first year and
a half yeah i was i'll say it's only
until recently i guess
got the upper hand from the public
you know i mean i think for the first
year and a half every
majority 60 70 70 of people were on
megan's side because she is a woman and
right now i'm not saying it's a wrong
thing please don't quote me wrong on
this but we are in a society of protect
black women you know what i mean so a
lot of the the deciding what's going
towards megan yeah because the hound was
reported as well yeah people don't know
much about it yeah they only know what
they've read and if all those reports
are on her side the majority they said
the comments are saying it was just
obvious she was lying by like her like
the way she was
talking like they were just like she
looked like she was fake crying
i don't know about that but like because
she performed like a night after all
like two nights after twerking on stage
that made it so unbelievable for me at
first i was i was believing her
because
i just think vice versa like it would
that would never happen to a dude where
you say victor he was like being
victim-shamed yeah yeah true it's like
that's like a female thing but i feel
like we all have this like innate
yeah like to protect women on some level
i'm trying to get rid of it
equal rights equal left
um okay so let me see the super chats
oh what was the one that you were
forgetting to mention could you said i
forgot one ish could you read the one i
forgot um
i believe it was just human okay um new
male friends aren't paying for your
dinner without anything in return either
you got them next um
we heard that one i didn't i didn't i
didn't finish what i was saying about
that though like what i was trying to
say is when i make new male friendship
if i know that i just want to be friends
with them if we go and do anything i
make it a point to pay for myself
i can actually make it a point to pay
for myself i agree with that yeah like
from the jump so that you know like well
i know we're just friends i'm not
expecting anything from you so you
shouldn't expect anything from me
true
um okay so the super chats um
you want me to read that again because i
don't think they heard me um just
reading it one more one more time just
humane uh new male friends aren't paying
for you on dinner dates without you
getting anything in return either you
got them next meal or you're on a date
okay so then after that brook escalator
um pearl please explain to the lady in
the middle what anecdotal evidence is
and the quality to the conversation like
this oh i think i did this one yeah
two dollars from boy tight crazy laugh
as a cutie her friend
i would smash for real
um okay sentience pearl as your daddy
you're having sex with other men there
would be punishment when i return get
ready for work at the hospital keep up
the great work and new camera good looks
oh i said i'd call him daddy because he
sends me a lot of money like on super
chats oh nice like respectfully in like
the respectful way um
philip i challenge the girl in the
middle to call this guy up about
smashing and see if he's really just
enjoying her company
which one
the one have you hooked up with the guy
the 10 month guy
yeah yeah okay so he already got you got
it yeah
um that's what you're going through 90
free to toe free toe pee oh free toe pie
free toe pie is how you say it lol um
also whatever a woman feels about her
flower is how a man feels about his time
how does a fish teach a shark just human
generally speaking men want sex women
want a relationship using a man's means
knowing the guy was knowing the guy
wants sex and using him for dates
attention and tasks for a woman it's
knowing she wants a relationship and
using her for sex um are there any that
i miss does it okay
okay um so does anyone i think the
general consensus here is we all think
megan the stallion's crazy
like right
i i think more along the lines of our
justice system innocent until proven
guilty um
is not for me to say he has nothing to
do with me but
but okay so you don't allegations [ __ ]
up your name
we're in that era where you'll be
blackboard just off allegations 100
exactly because it's like you see like
in in my personal opinion that maybe
this is going off topic a bit
if somebody accuses you of grape
and you go to prison for grape but you
didn't grape them but you're still under
sex offenders you're still a registered
sex offender worldwide
or even if you're not convicted you'll
see even if you get squashed
i don't think i don't think girls should
be able to like accuse someone unless
they're willing to press charges like
publicly
like i don't think like that should be
like put your money where your mouth is
yeah press charges
it's it's deep for a lot of people
though like imagine going through that
experience and you're not really wanting
you just want i guess to feel peace in
some respects but then you have to
relive them
and you just want some sort of justice i
tell you it's not worth it just don't
just say [ __ ] the potential justice and
leave it i promise you that that's okay
back in blood
wait what do you wait
it's happened to them okay but the
lengths to have to go to to get some
degree of justice it's more of a
headache to do that yeah it's not worth
it i promise you it'd be not because you
have to go to like court
it could be it could be you have to
relive all the experiences it could be
that you don't want the attention no no
no
fair enough
right fair enough but the problem is
like if if people can like start coming
forward and like being given platforms
off social media with no evidence it's
like
i i just think if you're if you're going
to do that you have to press charges
because some women will what some women
will even though they know nothing's
been done
the big brother yeah the big brother um
it was like celebrity big brother and
one it's not great but it was like it
was like domestic abuse
and he went he went like that with her
like just gently
barely even touching her and she was
like she laughed in the moment and then
she went into the room crying to one of
the other housemates saying he hit me
and then she circulated that narrative
to say and then she cried she went in
front of big brother even when he was
trying to defend himself she would hear
him and cry and she pushed that
she continued and the guy was like i
didn't like it ruined him do you know
what i'm trying to say and so i'm saying
based on that there will be women who
know that men or women who know they're
wrong and they would press charges and
still go ahead with it just to save face
right but like you have to have evidence
and so i'm saying like at least at least
if you press charges the evidence comes
out yeah i think it's just as long as
everyone is being held accountable so
like if if it comes out that it's not
true you should be punished because yeah
you are like say in that case you are
ruining someone's life but then you have
not true versus true but couldn't be
proven
yeah
right yeah but that's what i'm saying
like
if it comes to like where you can prove
that it's like it's falsified yeah you
should be punished yeah i think you
should get double the amount of talent
because you should get like people
should be afraid to do that and i just
don't think girls are like they just
know they're it's a joke i think i can i
can see where you're coming from about
like me too empowering people to like
take advantage of the system
um
and
yeah like it is very unfortunate
especially like when there are so many
people that are actually like victims to
whatever but because of these people
that are taking advantage of the system
they are not able to seek justice or
anything it's double-edged swords right
so if you make it if you if you have
tougher punishments for people with
light the genuine ones might be like i
might i don't want to speak now because
what if somebody thinks that i'm lying
what if i get found out i think at least
i think would you rather have a guilty
man in jail or an innocent or a guilty
man walk
free so like what's worse like is it
worse to have someone i'm sorry sorry
someone innocent an innocent man in jail
or a guilty man might walk free i'd
rather have like
the
like that's why i think it's it's
innocent until proven guilty you have to
prove it
but like i think there's a problem in
society when we're using the court of
public opinion
because you can you can spin clips and
like fuel your narrative and ruin
someone's career without having any
evidence
and that like like there has to be some
sort of punishment for this but even if
they're not found guilty as well their
lives are ruined yeah just because
you've accused them of something
if i think like in this case with megan
the stallion if it's if it comes that
she was lying about this i think she
should like
there should be some sort of punishment
some sort of punishment i would say i i
would be okay with her facing jail time
to be honest i i take it that seriously
if you want to ruin a man's car
he could get deported over this yeah he
could literally get deported wait he's
not an american he's connected he's
canadian oh yeah and so he could get
deported he like i'm sure he's lost
financial opportunities if you want to
do that and you were lying go to jail
like you deserve prison time like what
kind of messed up person would do that i
would never in a million years acute
like accuse someone of doing something
they didn't do
so if you're willing to do that like
what kind of person are you you are
literally i think you are a bad person
if you do that i think you should go to
jail i think that is necessary because
like um
a next friend of mine she was dealing
with this guy
she liked him more than he liked her and
then after she was like gonna cry wolf
and i'm just like no that's [ __ ] up
like you you didn't want to have sex
with him just because now he's saying oh
i don't relationship you can't say oh no
like and i think the difference is is
if people actually went through these
things that they're claiming they would
never they would never be willing to
falsify these things because you know
how true and like how how severe it can
be for you to even fix your mouth to say
oh this happened no the [ __ ] it didn't
like let the truth be the truth and if
your feelings get hurt let your feelings
be hurt and move on yeah well some
people are so vindictive whereby all
right you hurt me i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
and i'm not gonna give a [ __ ]
yeah but that's not good i'm not that
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't go to the
extent of saying oh yeah you raped me
great grapes me but
i would do other things i might smash up
your car yeah but i feel like i feel
like you're doing it i feel like you're
doing it to a man who probably deserves
it yeah so but who are you to say that
they deserve it no but i said it not
fair
if who
i'm saying she she you said you would
you would do that you would like be
vindictive i wouldn't take you to the
extent of life
false accusations but i would if
somebody hurts me yeah because you see
me i'm a person i'm very very nonchalant
i don't really care about much so if you
really really hurt me like no yeah you
you've hurt my heart if you put yourself
out there and somebody made you regret
putting yourself out there
is that enough for you to be like you
know what you've hurt me i'm [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up you see something's here
some things yeah i i leave to god
but you see sometimes i have to be calm
more i have to dress up as karma yeah
because god god be taking his time
sometimes like that's [ __ ] up because
it's violation i sat here and i said
yeah megan probably felt violated i
couldn't relate because there have been
times where i have felt violated let me
tell you let me give you an example yeah
um i when i was with my ex like
i took a lot of [ __ ] from him
then you see when it was all said and
done
that i was there i felt so violated i
felt so
violated it was keeping me up at night i
couldn't even sleep that's how violated
i felt yeah but you see yeah as soon as
i violated him back bro i had the best
night's sleep ever
and that's what it is like some people
actually like that's the payback and
some hundred percent some people
sometimes that's real [ __ ] well some
people would actually make allegations
of great justice
allegations
even if it's just an allegation
no i'm i don't co-sign like
lion i'm not i'm not a liar on many
things you can call me vindictive you
can call me manipulative you can call me
toxic but you can never call me a liar
um
wait
so
like i don't understand you you smashed
his car
i would if i needed to if i thought why
not just take yourself out of the
situation and leave
i've already left i've already left but
you see even if i've already left and
i'm still sitting there and i'm still
violated i'm still feeling violated
and i still and i can't see yeah
i need to go get it back in blood why
it's just i it's
not to be an attack on you but i think
it is emotional insecurity and um like
some like you have to not immaturity not
in security but um immaturity and
like yes it it is in that sense because
if you know that it's like it doesn't at
the end of the day it doesn't amount to
anything
like how it's like oh like you're going
to make this person make you the lesser
person it is technically making you the
lesser person even if you feel that you
should like retaliate you don't have to
the situation still remains the same i
leave yeah
at the same time i hear it because if if
like a man
like a violation's a violation yeah i
need to get back trying to understand
100 that's so childish that's like hit
me hit you back like to me it's like i
don't have to deal like after a certain
age you don't have to deal with people
so like so if i so if i have beef with
someone i just i'm done dealing with you
100 i just don't like why why are you
going to go through the immaturity to do
something
do you understand you keep interrupting
like what you're saying
so so when
i'm saying like why would you go through
like
hitting someone back or like doing
something back to them when like that's
illegal you could get in trouble for
that
because what you're saying is 100 right
yeah like you are supposed to be the
bigger person yeah
but it's so [ __ ] hard it's difficult
yeah like it's not that easy you have to
get like it's like my sister calling me
saying some man did whatever ex punched
her up and i'm just gonna remove
yourself from the situation he's gonna
i'm gonna wanna do something to him i'm
not saying i'm justified but if i feel
like that then i can understand a girl
in that situation feeling like if i feel
violated i feel violated and it takes a
lot to make me feel violated and if
you've pushed me to the point where i
feel violated then you're going to have
to feel violated too that's just how it
goes it's not about being emotionally
immature because it's not everybody
it's
if i feel violated it's because you've
hurt me to my core yeah and i can't let
that go so easily well the issue is that
like for me if someone's violated you
yeah but well if you were saying earlier
about you're a people pleaser and
so those are your own issues you're a
people pleaser so you meet up with a guy
a guy wants to have sex he doesn't know
that you're a people pleaser he's just
trying to get lucky he gets lucky you
feel [ __ ] about having sex with him you
now feel violated because you feel [ __ ]
and you didn't want to feel [ __ ] and now
you're going to say that he raped you or
no i feel like i feel like it would be a
deeper violence
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] up whereas this you
can say all right you know what there's
context here there's beef there there's
violation but some people act like there
is violation right actually even when
there is a violation
if a man puts his hands on me and i
can't fight him i'm gonna feel violated
and i'm gonna have to get back in blood
because you know what my mom didn't push
me out a hole for no man to be putting
their hands on me you understand yeah so
it's like there's certain things that
like even furthermore yeah when i'm
getting back at people it's usually only
people who i've probably been in a
relationship with and they violated me
and at the end of the day i will get my
get back and then after i've got my get
back they will still try and get me back
and at that point i will no no my
biggest revenge is for you to know that
you can never touch me again
yes i won so for for you is violation
like like physical abuse it can be
anything it depends on what it is
if someone's deeply psychological abuse
it could be cheating it could be putting
me at risk it could be anything
so you're doing something illegal over
anything you think doing something
illegal over anything
like cheating like even she doesn't
always have to be illegal though right
okay let's take cheating like it's like
you pick them
pick better
i agree i understand what you said
you don't get with people thinking that
they're going to cheat on you yeah yeah
but we see signs there's a woman you see
the signs you know ultimately you're
right but it's it's imprint no one it's
impractical no one's gonna
no one's gonna be in in the moment ben
cheated on and like it was my own damn
fault i picked him like everything i
just like yeah like it was seriously it
was my own for it's your own fault like
you pick i just think everything like
you were out of control
so you don't agree i don't agree do you
know what i disagree with you because
you see what you're saying here i
understand what you're saying here if
it's in a thing word you know what
you've cheated on me i know that you've
cheated on me and i'm gonna stay with
you so that you can continue to cheat on
you no one does that yeah obviously if i
find out you cheat on me obviously i'm
gonna leave you in it but until that
point nobody's asking to get cheated on
but i think most of the time girls see
signs and they don't listen like girls
like the bad boys
they we do statistically like we're
sometimes
no literally statistically we're more
likely to go for an offender rather than
someone
that doesn't have a criminal record like
reproduce with that but do you know what
i just think here that most guys cheat
anyway
i said most not all well you realize so
you realize the reason like women like
that's not true because like one out of
every
is it three is a three or four men one
out of every three men under one and
three that's why i thought one in three
men under 30 are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year the
reason
they're waiting 10 months
of other people no so so the reason the
reason that like women hate men or think
they cheat or whatever is because we're
all sleeping with the same ones if you
ask 80 of women what to list what they
want in a man they list 20 of men
sometimes 10 sometimes 5 percent i don't
sleep with men
they have to wait ten to eleven to
twelve to even yeah
wait right that's what i'm saying so
like if we choose to go for the small
percentage of guys that every girl wants
like if we get cheated on like we picked
them
because most guys can't cheat they don't
have the option to
i don't know what guys you're talking
about
guys
the same with the same guys that you
girls see as invisible yeah like you
don't see them you don't see them you
you just you they're wall passed in the
streets i don't know who you're talking
about
that's why
can we say like in this statistic like
because we have four guys here
have any of you cheated yeah i've
treated you before
that's just
sports
nah of course
no but i feel like i said man like
what man hasn't cheated i'll be honest
it depends what you mean by cheating if
you're just seeing multiple girls no no
no if you're exclusive with someone um
yeah but what's this
a relationship always experiencing
relationships
if you know that you're both like
exclusively seeing each other exclusive
you're my woman
no is it like you have to define it
properly relationship or exclusive
because exclusive stuff doesn't mean i'm
in a relationship all right relationship
yeah
um you cheated on the relationship i'm
married so like no before your marriage
no but if i'm in a relationship i'm in a
relationship but if i'm just getting to
know people when i'm just seeing people
for me some people might say that's
cheating
no i'm just saying if you're in a
relationship not not just dating but
yeah mm-hmm
i've been gia no
and but also like you realize the men
like i typically invite on this podcast
tend to be like better looking because i
like in general i recruit people that
are like good looking on this podcast so
a lot of times like the men we're
talking about like the one and three men
that haven't had sex like they're not
getting invited to be honest
that's why there's a small amount of men
that are like [ __ ] all the girls yeah
a very small percentage of men that i
like women only swipe right like five
percent of the times on dating apps
because we always saying
right they already got the the i don't
use data
go on
well that's the story here no i think
he's talking about that
yeah
pearl
got nothing super chats um
okay um let me see the super chats and
then
uh
[ __ ]
i keep guys i'm like kind of like an old
lady with this touch screen like i keep
touching it and like moving the
okay you remember the last one um
keep up the good okay ten dollars from
no name darkness keep up the good work
pearl
um
oh shoot what's his face um
what's his face um
i'm not gonna read i know i said i'd
read them while i'm not reading that one
um the spoken one a nominee should
apply to both the accused and the
accuser of grape accusations not just
for the accuser um brook escalator maybe
find an american dude for your panels it
would be nice to get a man's perspective
facts over feelings gentlemen homeboy on
the right seems based
um
two dollars from mickey mac weak men
like this have destroyed the west
we know who osman wait who is this
who's on the right i'm probably on their
right oh maybe
biased or based the best based
no based
based i think it's in american terms i
think it is biased
oh bias
no i think it's based right it's biased
base music is like no base means like
grounded oh
oh based so they're saying that he seems
grounded okay thank you
i think the one you do want to read was
relating to meg mega stallion so it was
a pun in words oh it was about meg the
stallion oh okay so okay i'll read it
that's so mean okay um clearly not
everyone wanted her high mileage wap
okay that was those magazines
um okay well
i i'm not sure if we agreed on anything
tonight
um maybe that meg the stallion's crazy
maybe
i think the situation the situation is
crazy yeah it's [ __ ] up it's just too
wishy-washy yeah
and the math just ate muffin i feel like
like he doesn't have gun residue on his
hand
like how could you not say that she's
lying about something if the man has
doesn't have gun residue on his hand
she's definitely lying she never got
shot and she stepped on the block yeah
there's there's no from when i saw this
and she was fighting
those weren't bullet wounds like yeah
it's not bullet wounds so so so we do
agree that she's
crazy close
that's crazy
okay yeah okay yeah yeah i get what you
mean you're lying about something
happening you're going on television
a national yeah
no crazy you got to be to take a lie
that far you're making a thing out of it
and it's like i think when two girls are
fighting over one guy
a situation never
a good situation never comes out of that
ever
and normally it's the women's fault i'll
be honest
with you is because the man can [ __ ]
whoever he wants but it's the women who
got to get emotional over it no because
you see guys if bro if that was if that
was your if that was your name what i'm
saying being in the next guy no but if
you're gonna get emotional
like let's say me and my boy yeah no me
and my boy are sleeping with one girl
now we're not you don't fight but you
don't know bro you don't know but you're
you're in there yeah you're on it if we
find out that we're sleeping with the
same girl bro
but like that's the comparison yeah
we're different like if you flip it now
and it's two guys and it's one girl it's
like we're not getting overly emotional
but because it was kelsey but it depends
it depends if your guy is saying yeah
that's my thing now
and if if he's if he's saying that
that's mine and he can't have it but you
know what he's just sleeping though yeah
but yeah but you feel like nah that's
mine like if you both feel like now
she's mine you can't beat them you feel
what i'm saying it might it might get
there it depends on what the beef was in
the in the whip or in the whatever bro
you see one thing with that yeah it's
like as men we know not to beef over
women
because a lot of the
wars have started like i'm talking about
historical wars i've started over women
you know what i mean we've heard from
them that being said that guy that model
who got stabbed to death was overall
yeah but like i was gonna say something
else but to be fair they weren't even
friends to be fair so yeah i can't even
say that but yeah it does happen yeah it
does
it does but i agree with you more time
man i don't think it's the rule though i
think most of the time dudes will just
be like oh [ __ ] how okay and then like
yeah
no you'll be surprised actually certain
men are very territorial with their
girls so it's like they will look at a
girl they've
they've had and they'll be like no one
should touch that and they'll feel the
type of way you guys do release a
hormone during sex that makes you more
territorial that is true um like that
women don't so that's why like a lot of
times guys will sleep with a girl and
even though they like really want
nothing to do with her they still kind
of feel some type of way and then the
next guy comes as i'm saying my boy's
piping you that's a weird bro
even if you're whole your beat is just a
brown color no it's nasty it's
definitely nasty but then why would a
girl win a homie hop anyway that's true
sometimes you get even
some girls do to get even you've never
seen that in tick tock when they're like
oh f is friend
yeah that is very weird but hey teachers
aren't
violations okay well i i still don't
think we
i think we kind of agree that toriel
that that megan the stallion's crazy
mm-hmm yeah okay cool
majority yeah yeah it's always easy to
call the female crazy though i'm just
going to put that out there
not something i think it's when she's
like doing crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah women
all crazy
okay guys um why don't we go around say
any closing thoughts that you guys have
um go ahead
um yeah i don't believe i'm i'm with i'm
team tory i can't know that's that's
what i'll say okay yeah
i just think
that
like i've been saying i reckon kelsey
and meg was fighting over tory and i
can't wait for it to all go to court and
then we can all watch it just like the r
kelly situation
um
i'm not on anyone's side but i do think
you know you should
um
see what people are wanting from the
relationship like
make sure that you're on the same page
with people
that you're sleeping with yeah um
i do believe megan got shot not by tori
um
i feel like believe facts believe
evidence
of a believing people
that's it really
i think it's a [ __ ] show um
i think
i don't know what to believe uh i don't
know if i care if i want to know what to
believe um
yeah men like women lie
um whoever's lying i hope they get done
for
whoever's telling the truth i hope they
get some sort of vindication but
yeah
they live there
okay well um
guys if you want to follow any of the
guests today all their instagrams and
like youtube channels are in the
description thank you guys so much for
coming um i really apprec i think it's
good to have like
talks with people even if we don't
always like see things the right way i
think that's what makes this show very
special so i appreciate all of you
coming
um
okay guys thank you so much for the
super chats as you guys know the super
chats are being used for another camera
so like all super chats are being used
towards that i really appreciate it i
couldn't do these shows without the
super chat so i really appreciate it
don't forget to like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and for
real like that video it's free okay it's
real free and we're gonna start doing
members only chat soon so if you wanna
keep commenting privileges you're gonna
have to sign up for a membership i'm
giving you guys warnings it's going away
soon um don't forget to subscribe and
i'll talk to you guys next time
[Music]
um
yeah it is
like but it's gonna be a close one